[Music]
hey everyone
welcome to the simply learns full course
video on google cloud platform
in this video we will learn everything
about gcp in detail
we will begin this full course video
with what gcp
is then we will look into gcp and its
concepts
in detail then our expert will give you
a quick training on azure services
then we will see what's the differences
between aws and gcp
next we'll see what gcp web hosting is
after that we will be looking into
google cloud machine learning and
finally
we will conclude this video by
discussing the google cloud platform
fundamentals certification training by
the end of this video
i can assure you that gcp your gcp
make sure to subscribe to our youtube
channel and hit that bell icon
to never miss an update from simply
learn
good morning and good evening everyone
so welcome to this
session on google cloud platform my name
is aj
and i'm an instructor with simplylearn
and
also working as a big data and cloud
architect for various clients across
globe in this session
we learn about google cloud platform
wherein we will learn about what is
cloud computing
why google cloud platform what is gcp
that is google cloud platform google
cloud platform domains
about a use case that is federal use
case and
also a quick demo on using services
from google cloud platform so when we
talk about
google cloud platform we also need to
know what is cloud computing
so cloud computing is the use of
hardware
and software components to deliver a
service to a network
users can access these files and
applications
and services provided by a cloud
provider
from any device that has access to
internet
in short cloud computing is a way where
cloud provider provides access to
different services such as resources and
when we talk about resources here
we talk about computing we talk about
memory
we talk about processing power we talk
about storage
and we also talk about different
services
which cloud providers make available for
the users now that allows us
for automatic software integration
backup and restoring data
unlimited storage capacity having a
reliable
use of different services and
having a cost efficient solution
now we know that cloud computing
models there are different service
models so you have platform as a service
you have infrastructure as a service and
you have
software as a service and these are the
prominent models which are offered by
different cloud providers such as google
cloud
such as google you have amazon you have
azure
and also some organizations build their
own private clouds
using open source openstack let's
focus more on google cloud platform and
what
it has to offer and how it is gaining
popularity in the market
with different organizations which would
want to work
on a cloud platform or which would want
to work
on an infrastructure which is
modernized so when we talk about cloud
computing this is one of the approach
which organizations can take to
instantaneously
benefit from modernization using
different services
different platforms and also newer
technologies
for their various requirements such as
scalability
or dynamic businesses before we get into
google cloud platform
it is also good to understand
where you can find some useful resources
about google cloud platform
and here you have a website which is
from your google cloud so this is
cloudacademy.com
library slash google and here you can
create
a free account now that would give you
just seven days trial but that has a lot
of
videos which talk about your google
cloud platform
and essentials and it has various
certification related videos which you
can access
and then after seven days after you have
tried
you can obviously go for a paid account
where you can take detailed learning
from here
now this is your training library which
shows your different cloud providers
such as amazon
microsoft seo gcp
and then you have various other topics
which are specifics
to organization you can obviously look
at the pricing
and you can also look at resources which
will give you a good
experience in learning from these videos
you can also create a free account which
i will
walk you through later so you can create
a free
account on cloud.google.com now when i
say free account
that basically means it allows you to
create an account
and every user who creates an account
gets a 300
free credit which can be used to
practice
brush up your skills and also explore
and learn about different google cloud
products which are offered by google
now coming back to our google cloud
platform
let's understand why google cloud
platform
so google cloud platform is popular for
many reasons
now let us see a few of most important
reasons why it stands out
when you talk about pricing pricing is
one of the significant
factors that make google cloud stand out
among the other
cloud providers it offers a monthly
pricing plan
which is built according to monthly
usage and when we talk about billing
here
the billing can be in hours it can be in
minutes and it can also be in seconds
there are different options when you
talk about
your pricing which can be found from
your google cloud web page now
pricing could be based on preemptive
machines
pricing could be based on reserved
instances or reserved resources
i'll show you the link where you can
find more details on pricing
part of it so google cloud really
has various pricing options which help
customers in their different
requirements whether they would go for
any of the service models such as
infrastructure as a service platform as
a service
or even software as a service one more
attractive thing
about google cloud pricing is that it
provides committed
use discounts for example under this
scheme
you can purchase a specific amount of
virtual cpu cores
and memory for up to 57 percent discount
of
regular prices if you commit usage for
either one or three years now this is
just
one option there are various such
options which you can learn about from
the google cloud
page and that really suits
different customers for their different
requirements
now when we talk about speed we don't
need to really
challenge this aspect when it comes to
google services
so google provides its google cloud and
google app
customer speed up to 10 terabytes
because of its
faster cable system there are different
kind of
machines which can be used if you are
talking about computation
if you are talking about memory hungry
applications
or even storage intensive workloads
all in all speed is one of the defining
characteristics of google cloud services
the cable has connections over u.s west
coast
main cities in japan and even major hubs
in asia
this speed enhances performances and
leads to customer satisfaction
now when we talk about customers any or
every customer would prefer to have
low latency high throughput based
services they would want to use higher
speeds to process their data
in as less time as possible google
provides a low latency network
infrastructure
in fact you can say that when you are
using google cloud services
you are using the services from the same
infrastructure which google uses
for its popular services such as google
search
or even youtube which is one of the
second largest
repository which can be accessed for
videos
now when we talk about big data big data
is
data which is very complex has
lot of other characteristics such as
your volume
you have velocity you have variety
you have veracity validity volatility
virality and so on so if an organization
has
is working on big data google cloud can
be
a better choice because google has many
innovative tools for cloud warehousing
for example such as bigquery
and even real-time data processing tools
such as data flow
bigquery is a data warehouse that allows
massive
processing of data at high speeds
basically working on your structured
data google also has launched some new
machine learning from
artificial intelligence tools now there
are various other services
which we can which we can use from
google cloud platform but let's
understand what is google cloud platform
and what are some of the services even
the services which are not listed
here can be found in your console
from google cloud so what is google
cloud platform gcp
it is a set of cloud computing services
provided by google
that runs on the same infrastructure as
i mentioned
that google uses for its end user
products like youtube
gmail and even google search the various
set of services
offered by google cloud platform are so
you have services which are
specific to computing requirements and
again in computing
you have various different options
available
you have machines which are compute
optimized
machines which are memory optimized
machines which are storage optimized
and also we have certain machines such
as pre m tiff
which basically means that you could get
a machine
to work on at a far lesser price
than any other machine but when we talk
about
preemptive these are the machines which
can be
requested on demand and they can be
taken back
by google at any time you have
networking related services
which can be very useful when you are
setting up your applications or your
services
across globe you also have different
services which are specific to
machine learning and organizations which
would be interested in
working on machine learning or
artificial intelligence
would be really interested in using
these services
there are also innovative solutions to
work
on big data and big data related
technologies
now when we talk about google cloud
platform domains
so we can break down these services
into specifics such as you have compute
now the compute service allows for
computing
and hosting the cloud now when you talk
about computing
here there are different services such
as
app engine you have compute engine you
have kubernetes
you have cloud functions and cloud run
when you talk about storage and database
so
the storage and database service allows
application to store
media files backups or other file-like
objects now various services under this
are as follows
you have cloud storage cloud sql
cloud big table for unstructured data
you have cloud spanner
cloud data store persistent disks
and cloud memory store when we talk
about networking
the networking service allows us to load
balance traffic
across resources now as i mentioned
earlier resources could be
your different resources which you would
be using from a cloud platform such as
your devices your instances
memory optimized or cpu optimized
instances
or other resources creating dns records
and much more so various services under
this
are vpc that stands for virtual private
cloud
you have cloud load balancing cloud
armor
cloud cdn you have cloud interconnect
dns and network service tiers when we
talk about the big data service
this allows us to process and query big
data
in cloud now various services under
these are as follows you have bigquery
cloud cloud data proc cloud composer
cloud data lab
cloud data prep cloud pubs up which is
publish and subscribing
system you have cloud data studio now
you also have
the developer tools and developer tools
service includes tools related to
development of an application now
various services under these are as
follows
that is you have cloud sdk software
development kit
you have deployment manager cloud source
repositories
and cloud test lab when we talk about
identity and security
which is one of the primary concerns for
any organization or any user
who would be interested in using a cloud
platform
google cloud really has taken care of
this
so when you talk about identity and
security domain this deals with
security services now various services
here are cloud identity you have
identity and access management that is
cloud iam
you have identity aware proxies you have
cloud data loss prevention api
security key enforcement key management
service and many more you also have
cloud services which are related to
internet of things
so very much would be used by
organizations
who would be working on iot devices or
the data generated
by these devices so various services
here
are cloud iot core you have edge tpu
and cloud iot also when we talk about
cloud ai that is artificial intelligence
this comprises of
services related to machine learning and
much more
so you have cloud auto ml cloud tpu
cloud machine learning engine job
discovery
dialog flow enterprise natural language
cloud
text to speech and much more if
you would be interested in services
related to api
platform then there are different
services under this category or this
domain
so you have maps platform you have apg
api platform monetization developer
portal
analytics that is api analytics apg
sense cloud endpoints and service
infrastructure
so these are some of the listing of
services
under each cloud platform domain now
let's look at
ferrero use case and let's also
understand
what was done here so ferraro
is one of the famous chocolate and ranks
third among
worldwide chocolate and confectionary
producers
it was found in 1946
in italy i'm sure you would have seen
the ferrero chocolates
when you would have gone out to buy some
chocolates
so the challenges here was that federal
as we know
is sold in every supermarket and is
known for its quality
once the business grew some issues arose
right and that's what happens when the
business grows you have
issues popping up which could be related
to
the volume of data the speed with which
the data is getting generated
the variety of data and also looking at
your platforms which support
different dynamic applications or your
scalability requirements
performance requirements and so on so it
needed data storage
processing and analysis system for a
wide
customer database there was a huge gap
between the company and the people who
bought its goods because the company
relied on data given sales outlets now
that's one of the challenge
ferro wanted to create a digital
ecosystem
where there was a point of contact with
its customers
and also a foundation for an innovative
data-driven marketing strategy what was
the solution here
so one of the service of cloud platforms
or google cloud platform
is bigquery and this was an answer to
ferraro's challenges
since it was capable of hyper fast and
efficient
data analysis as a solution now as i
mentioned bigquery is a data warehouse
which allows you to store
structured data now this could directly
be used as a service
where you could store in any amount of
data
and you would not be paying for
storage so there are different pricing
models and
for data up to one terabytes you would
not be charged anything
and if you would be accessing the data
that is reading the data or processing
the data from bigquery
that's where the pricing model kicks in
now using google cloud's bigquery
business analysts of federal were able
to store
and analyze massive data sets in a very
reliable fast and affordable manner
consumer behavior and sales pattern data
reports were easy to build
and automate and the analysis
also followed federal to adopt
advertising
across various marketing channels to
serve the customer needs in a better way
what was the result they could divide
their database
into real-time actionable consumer
clusters to generate more accurate
user profiles ferro was also
able to personalize its marketing
strategies
to match the user needs now google cloud
platform
completely tailored the website mobile
content
and advertising and created a very cost
effective media
buy strategy now these were some basics
on google cloud now as i said you can
always find lot of details
about pricing about services
and also all the services are accessible
in your free trial account now let me
just walk you through here
so one is you could always find details
on documentation on each of these
services
so if i would click on getting started
you have quick start which basically
shows you
short tutorials you have trainings and
you have
also certifications now if we click on
quick start
now that takes me to this page which
shows me
quick starts or if you would want to
understand about different projects
if you would want to look into the
documentation of creating a linux
virtual machine or storing a file and
sharing it
deploying a container docker container
image
and so on so you have a lot of quick
starts here you can also look at cloud
minute
on the same page on the right side you
have docs
and once you click on that it takes you
to these
links now this shows you build solutions
which shows your top use cases best
practices
all the solutions it's always good to
learn from these use cases which are
available
and here you have different feature
products
and all the different services which
google cloud offers
now you can click on featured products
and that basically
shows you a list of these products now
here
we have all the solutions which you can
look at architecture database
enterprise level big data and analysis
gaming
related internet of things and so on now
if you go down here
it shows you featured products and that
shows you
some of the important products such as
compute engine which is
belonging to the compute domain you have
cloud run
you have anthus which is for migration
and basically cloud adoption
when organizations would want to move
from on-premise to cloud-based solutions
you have vision ai
you have cloud storage now that
basically allows you to store
any kind of data whether that's an
object
so this is acting as an object storage
you have cloud sql which is basically a
ready to use
service where you would be using mysql
postgres or any other sql server
database services
you have bigquery which is a data
warehouse which basically allows you to
store your structured data
and then you have your ai and machine
learning related products
so you have auto ml vision ai video ai
text to speech speech to text and so on
now you also have different platform
accelerators
which can be used and in any of these
cases for example if i would click on
compute
engine which is a featured product from
google cloud
now that shows you basically your quick
starts
using your linux machines how to guides
which tells you
completely working on a vm instance
or working on storage working on
persistent disks and so on
and it shows you the documentation here
now you
also have products and pricing option
which you can see for gcp pricing and
you could straight away go to the
pricing
you could be looking at solutions which
talks about infrastructure modernization
now this is something which
organizations are interested in
when they would want to move from their
on-premise
solution to your google cloud now here
i can say for example i click on
infrastructure modernization
you can always find some case studies
what are the different solutions
we have here right when you talk about
google cloud
so you can always click on see solutions
and you can look at vm migration or sap
cloud
right why google cloud what it can be
used for vmware as a service
or hpc that is high performance
computing
and about these services we will learn
in detail
later now i can go back on the same page
where i was clicking on the services so
you have quick starts
you have how to guides you have deep
understanding of different concepts
right
and here if i click on all how to
guides so that shows me what are the
different ways in which you can work
with compute
engine and working with different
instances although it's
quite exhaustive content but then if you
follow steadily then you can learn a lot
about
google cloud now here i can just go back
so this is just giving you some idea on
the different products
which are available from google cloud
looking into different
sections finding right documentation
here
right and you can always look into each
one of these
in detail for each product which google
cloud
offers now if we scroll
down we could see all the options or all
the domains which we see here
right let me just go back because we got
into solutions
now we have quick starts right and then
you can
basically scroll all the way down to
look at cloud sdk which can be set up on
your windows machine like i have set it
up on my windows machine
plus when you use google console you
have
a gui which i'll show you in couple of
minutes
and also a cloud shell where you can use
your command line options to work with
google cloud platform you have cloud
console
which is nothing but your gui to access
your resources
now you can also look at in-depth
tutorials pricing
and you have different other options so
let's just click on pricing here and
then we have
your price list which basically gives
you details
of different services what are available
and what are the services or what are
the prices so for example if i click on
compute
engine right and this shows me the
pricing
aspect of compute engine which belongs
to compute domain
and here you can see you have vm
instance pricing you have networking
pricing
sole tenant nodes which are specific to
particular organizations or if
organizations would want to have
dedicated nodes
you have gpu based pricing right so
general processing units you have disk
and image pricing and you can click on
any of the links and you can see
pricing which also shows you your
different kind of machine types so here
you have different kind of machine types
which says
n1 n2 n2d e2
you have memory optimized machine types
you have compute optimized
you have premium images and you can
basically look at all the categories you
can look at disk pricing which involves
your persistent disk pricing for ssds or
sdds what are the kind of images what
are the different
network services right and you can
always look at
your machine types you can choose a
particular region
right there is the concept of region and
availability zones here
and as per region you could look at the
prices
you can also look at standard prices you
could be looking for what are the free
tier machines
if i'm specifically looking for vm
instance pricing i can click on this one
and that takes me to the vm instance
pricing what is the billing module
what is the instance up time what is the
resource-based pricing
and then you can also look at different
kind of discounts such as sustained use
discounts committed use discounts
discounts from preemptable vm instances
and so on and this is how you can be
looking at pricing for
all different resources and you can
choose the resource which you are
interested in
and then look for the pricing benchmarks
reservations if you would want to use
and you would want to benefit
if you would want to look at what are
the quotas and limits and so on
so please explore this link and you can
find lot of information when it comes to
technical
options looking at different google
cloud products which we briefly
discussed
when it comes to domains and what each
product can be used for
you can always come back to the main
page where i was showing you different
services we went into pricing straight
away
right now you can always come back to
this page
on your cloud.google.com and then you
have your solutions
which talks about different products
right and you can click on these
or you can look into technical
documentation so this talks about
your different featured solutions
infrastructure solutions you have data
center migration related
and so on so i could be talking more and
more about google cloud platform
it's a ocean it's a huge chunk of
different
services for different organizational
requirements
so look into this link and also what you
can do
is create a account on gmail
i mean you could create a free account
or you could go to cloud.google.com
and then you could create a free account
like i have created here
and i can just click on console now
that's my gui
or google cloud console which basically
allows me to
work with google cloud now there are a
lot of options here
by default when you create an account
now in my case
on the top it says it's a free trial
account i have 300
credit and out of that 251 dollars is
left
and 237 days out of a year are left for
my account
now here i can basically see the project
right and by default we can create a
project
or by default there is a project
existing for any user
so when you log in it creates a
particular project
and you could create a new project and
project would be
to dedicate your different services or
different resources per different
project
so this is your dashboard which
basically shows your project which shows
you a project
number and a project id which is always
unique
now you can click on this and this if
you would want
you can hide this information you can
also look into the documentation part of
it
then it shows you the different services
or
a graphical information of services
which you might have used in past
so you have compute engine which shows
you how much percentage of cpu was used
you can always go to compute engine as a
service you can look at your google
route
platform status and look at the google
cloud status
now this is billing now since this shows
me
the billing period for april month and i
can always look at detailed charges
i can look at reporting i can look at
different apis
which google offers and you for your
different kind of work
you can always go to the api overview or
the api link
and enable or disable any api now once
you enable or disable any api
then you can use that so you have new
section
you have documentation and you have
getting started guides which tells you
how to work
or enable different apis if you would
want to deploy
a pre-built solution add dynamic logging
monitoring errors
deploying a hello world app and so on
now this is your dashboard
i can click on activity and that would
show me
what kind of activity i would have done
in my cloud platform i can always choose
the kind of
activities by saying activity type
i can choose the resources now it shows
me that i
created some vm instances i deleted them
i updated some metadata i basically
worked on
instances i changed some firewall rules
here i have then also worked on
some other services or apis so i created
some buckets which is for object storage
and again i have been working with some
instances and creating some firewall
rules
here i have granted some permissions i
am setting up a policy
right so this activity gives me a
history of what
things i have done over the past couple
of months
while working on google cloud platform
now
on the top left corner you have the
hamburger menu which you can click on
this so that's your navigation menu
and when you click on this this shows
you home it takes you to the marketplace
it specifically takes you to billing you
can always look at apis
and services so here in api services i
can
pretty much go to a dashboard and i can
see a
report on the traffic or errors or
latency and the kind of apis
which are available so you have compute
engine api you have bigquery api
bigquery data transfer api bigquery
storage cloud data proc so these are
some of the apis or services i've used
in past
might be i was evaluating a product
might be i was
using a particular product so you have
whenever you would want to use a
particular service from google cloud
platform
you would be enabling these apis so here
we see
some apis for data proc you have
logging monitoring you have resource
manager api you have cloud sql which
allows you to
directly use mysql or postgres
you have cloud storage right and so many
apis so if i would want to enable
a particular api which is not right now
required
but then it's good to know you can
always click on this one
you can search for an api so for example
if i would say data proc
right and that shows me the cloud data
proc api which manages hadoop based
clusters
and jobs on google cloud platform so i
can spin up a hadoop cluster
and i can start running some jobs on
a hadoop cluster on demand and as i'm
done with it
i can just get rid of it so this is an
api which i would have to enable
and then for every particular service
you also have an
admin api which you would enable
now going back so coming out from this
api library
i got into api and services now there is
you can look into the library you can
look at credentials
and you can also look at different
time intervals for which you can see the
usage
of your different apis now going back to
the menu
you have support wherein you can always
reach out to the google support team
if you are using a paid version
even with free trial you can try to
reach out and you will find someone to
help but it is always good when you have
a
billing cycle reaching out the customer
care you have
identity access management in admin and
this is required when you're working
with different apis or services
when you would want to have relevant
access you have getting started
you have security related options you
have anthos which is mainly for
migration now here you can look at your
different domains
such as which we discussed so you have
compute and in compute
you have different services so you have
app engine
you have compute engine kubernetes you
have cloud functions and cloud run
you can look into the storage aspect
which shows you bit table
which is usually and mainly for your
unstructured data
big table which is something which gave
rise to
popular nosql databases like hbase and
cassandra
you have data store which can be used
you have firestore
file store storage which can be used to
put in data of any kinds you have
sql for structured data you have spanner
as a service you have memory store and
you have
data transfer now when it comes to the
networking domain
you have all these services such as vpc
virtual private network
network related services for your load
balancing for using a cloud-based dns
or cloud defined network you have hybrid
connectivity
network service tiers security and
intelligence
then you have other options for your
operations which can be used
and here you have different other tools
which can be used
such as cloud build you have cloud tasks
container registry
deployment manager and many more big
data specific
you have the services here so you have
data proc which can be used to spin up
your clusters
you have published subscribe messaging
system such as now
kafka which you might have heard of
originates
its idea from here so pub sub you have
data flow
you have iot core bigquery which is a
data warehouse package
or data warehousing solution from google
cloud
now then you have your artificial
intelligence related
services and other google solutions so
you can always find a huge
list of services or you can say at high
level solutions
offered by google cloud and we can use
these
to basically test some of the solutions
use them and work on them so i'll give
you a quick
demo on different services which can be
used here
from your google cloud platform now this
is your google
cloud platform and this is your console
now this also gives you a cloud shell
which can be activated
so that you can work from command line
and you can always find a lot of
documentation on that
so you can also set up your cloud shell
that is sdk on your windows machine
and if you have set it up then basically
you could be doing something like
gcloud right if the cloud has been set
up
so in my case i had set up the cloud sdk
and basically i can get into that by
looking at
what path i have set up so cloud sdk
and then i can be using it from my
windows machine
as per my comfort i can also activate
the cloud shell here
which will basically open up a terminal
and at any point of time you can open up
this one cloud shell in a different
window it is preparing the cloud shell
where it will by default set up your
project
it will set up the metadata and now i am
logged into my
google cloud account from command line
and
here i can basically use gcloud
right and that basically shows you the
different options which are available
which you can be using so if you would
want to use
a particular service you can also try
giving a help
and that shows you how do you manage
your google cloud platform
right so you have different options for
billing to work with your different
services
and basically you could be working on
google cloud using this cloud shell from
your command line
usually for people who are learning
google cloud in the beginning
it is always good to go for console
and use your different services from
here in an easier way
but as i said you can always use the
command line for example if i would just
go ahead
and type gcloud create
instances and that will directly take me
to the cloud console documentation which
shows you
different options which you can use to
work with instances so i could do
a gcloud compute instances create and
then i can give my instance name and so
on and i'll show you some examples on
that
so you can be using your cloud console
right that is your cloud shell and you
can straight away start working
from command line however i would
suggest using console in the beginning
and when you are well experienced then
you can start using cloud shell to do
things from command line
and when you are fully experienced you
can always switch and certain things are
usually useful
or easier when done from command line
and some
are easier when you do it from the
console
and you can use any one of these options
now we can go to
google cloud console now as of now i can
close this one
i still have my cloud shell open if i
would want to look into it
i can click on this one and i can
straight away go to compute
engine where i would want to work on
creating
some instances on google cloud platform
using the compute engine service and
then basically connecting to those
instances
and basically trying out some basic
things so you can click on vm instances
and then once this comes up i can always
create some instances now if you see
here i have
some instances already created right and
i can continue working on those
i can create new instances i can use
different
options while creating instances and
i'll show you that
in a demo in quick seconds so
let's have a quick demo on setting up
gcp
instances now before that let's have a
quick recap
so when you talk about instance or a
virtual machine
it is hosted on google's infrastructure
right
and you can create your google cloud
instance
using this google cloud console that is
by
clicking on this and then going to
compute engine
and clicking on vm instances now you can
also do that from
google cloud command line tool that is
cloud shell
and you can be doing that using compute
engine
api so compute engine instances can
run the public images for linux or
windows servers
that google provides you also have
option of creating
or using custom images that you can
create and import from your
existing systems you can deploy docker
containers which are automatically
launched
on instance running containers optimized
os now when you talk about instances and
projects
always remember that in each instance
belongs to a
google cloud console project and a
project can have one or more instances
when you talk about instances and
storage options each instance
has a small boot persistent disk which
i will show you in further screens that
contains the os
you can add more storage space if needed
and when you talk about instances and
network a project can have up to
five vpc networks so vpc network is
virtual private networks
wherein you can virtual private cloud
networks
where you can have your resources within
your own
subnet and each instance belongs to
one vpc network now instances in
same network can communicate with each
other through local area network
protocol
an instance uses internet to communicate
within any machine so that could be
virtual
physical or outside its own network when
you talk about instances and containers
you should remember that compute engine
instances
support a declarative method for
launching
your application using containers now
you can create
a vm instance or a vm instance template
you can provide a docker image and
launch the configuration
so there are different ways in which you
can create these
instances and once you create these
instances
you can say for example you are creating
a linux instance
you can associate ssh keys with your
google account
or your g suite account and then manage
your admin
non-admin access to the instance using
im roles
if you connect to your instance using
gcloud
or ssh from console which we will see
later compute engine can generate
ssh keys for you and apply that to your
google cloud or g suite account
now what we can do is we can see how we
can create
your google cloud instances from your
console
or from the command line let's have a
look in creating
instances using gcp console
now that we have learned on some basics
of google cloud platform what are the
different services what are different
domains
basically looking at your google cloud
console
or even cloud shell let's go ahead and
create
some vm instances now that's from your
compute engine service
and let's try connecting to these
instances and see how this works
let's also see what are the different
options which are available when you
would want to create
the virtual machine instances here so
when you click
on your drop down from the top left and
choose
compute engine so it brings you to this
page so
i can show that again so you can click
on compute
engine click on vm instances and that
basically brings you to this page
now here it tells you compute engine
lets you use virtual machines that run
on google's infrastructure
so we can create micro vms or large
instances
running different distributions of linux
or windows
using standard images that is public
images and you can also have your own
image
so let's create a vm instance by
clicking on create
now that's basically helping me to
create an instance here
so it shows me the instance name i can
give it something so let me say
c1 now i can add labels
so what is label it basically allows you
to organize your project
add arbitrary labels as key value pairs
to your resources this so this is
basically categorizing
your labels and projects if you have
multiple projects
now remember if you have your cloud
console and if you have created your
free trial account
it will allow you to do these things if
not
you may have to go back to the billing
section and see if the billing is
enabled
which also means that when you are
creating your google cloud account
it will ask you to key in your credit
card details but they do not
charge anything or they might charge
might be one dollar or one rupee
depending on your location and that's
also refunded but that's just to verify
your card
now once i've given the name i can
choose a region
so i would basically choose europe since
i'm in europe i would be clicking on
europe west 3
and here i can choose an availability
zone
availability zone is basically to make
your services
or instances or any other resources
highly available so you can choose one
of the availability zones now i would
choose save s3
now this one we can scroll down and here
it says machine configurations you have
general purpose machines you have memory
optimized machines which is
m1 series and you can always go back to
the google cloud page and see
what a particular kind of machine
specializes in
so i would click on general's purpose
and in general purpose you have
different categories so you have
n1 which is powered by intel skylake cpu
platform or you have e2
which is cpu platform selected selection
based on availability so let's
have n1 selected now this one shows me
the machine type
and if you are using your free tier
account
then you can start with collecting a
micro machine
which is one virtual cpu core you can go
for a g1 small
which is one virtual cpu core and 1.7 gb
ram
you can even go up to a high-end machine
and then you can basically see if you
are using a free account
how many of these machines you can use
if i would be selecting eight virtual
cpu cores and
32 gigabyte of memory then it would
allow me to
create at least two instances by this
configuration
we will use n1 standard which is one
virtual cpu core
3.75 gb memory now then
we can also deploy a container image to
this vm instance
if you would be interested in deploying
a container image let's not get into
that right now
here it shows you the boot disk and it
shows you dbn
gnu 9 linux 9. what i would do is
i can go for this distribution or i can
choose
a linux distribution of my choice so
here you have public images you have
custom images you
also have snapshots if you have created
backup of your previous images
here i can choose for example ubuntu
and then i can choose a particular
version so let's go for ubuntu 18.04
you can go for the latest one also 18.04
would be
good enough and here it tells me what is
a boot disk
so you have ssds or you have standard
persistent disks
now ssds are a little expensive in
comparison to your standard persistent
disks or your sdds
but then ssds are faster so as of now we
can choose standard persistent disk
as it is and we can let the gigabyte be
10 now depending on your requirement you
can increase this
you can even add disks later that's not
a problem click on select
now here i have access scopes
so here i will say allow default access
you can also set access for each api
or you can give full access to all cloud
apis so that based on your requirement
you can anytime change later
also we will also say allow http traffic
and we can also choose allow https
traffic that basically allows me to
access this machine or services which
are http based
accessible from this machine now i can
just click on create
however it would be good to basically
enable connectivity to this machine
now we can do that in different ways one
is when you bring up your machine
it will have an ssh access which you can
log in from the cloud platform here
itself
or what you can do is you can create a
private and a public key
using some softwares like putty or putty
gen
so for example if you do not have that
on your machine
you can download you can just type in
download putty
that takes you to the putty.org page and
here you can click on download putty
and scroll down which shows you for your
64-bit machine
which i have in my case you can download
putty.exe
which is basically your ssh and telnet
client
to connect to your machines you can also
use puttygen
which will be allowing you to create a
private and a public key
which i have done in my case let me show
you how
so what you can do is you can go to
puttygen
to begin with and here you can click on
generate
now then to have this key generated just
move your cursor on the top here in the
empty space
and that creates your key you can give
it a name so for example
let's give a user name i would give hdu
now i can give a password for this one
so let me give a simple password
and what i can also do is i can
copy this public key from here and for
my later usage i can just keep it in my
notepad
file which i can use later and i'll show
you when
so now we can save this private key
and this will basically allow me to save
my private key i can choose desktop
and i can give it a name so let's say
new
key new key and that will be getting
saved in a dot ppk
file so let's save it and that's done so
we also have our public key and we have
saved our private key now we know
that when you would want to connect
using ssh you need your private keys to
the client
and public key also has to be existing
so let's take this
public key so let's do a control a i'm
going to copy this and i'm going to come
back to my google cloud console
and here you can click on security so
you can click on
the security tab here scroll down
and just give your public key once you
give that it resolves
and shows you the name and this is good
enough so that i can use
my ssh client to connect to this machine
i can click on create
and this will basically create my vm
instance
it will take some time and then your
instance will have an
internal ip which will show up here
external ip
and it will also show you options to
connect to these machines so this is my
internal ip this is my external ip which
i can use to connect from a client
i can easily connect from the option
here which says ssh
and i can say open in a browser window i
can
even open this in a custom port i can
look at the
gcloud command which you can give from
cloud shell
or you can use another ssh so let's
first do a open
in browser window and let's see if this
connects
so we can easily connect to our instance
in the ubuntu 18
instance which i just set up here easily
in couple of seconds
now this is trying to establish a
connection using your ssh keys
and when you do that it also basically
brings up this web browser so i'm
already connected
it shows my username which is my cloud
account username and i have been
connected to this machine here
using ssh it did not ask me for any
password
and basically now i can just check
what do i have in my linux file system
right and i can
anytime login as root by doing a sudo su
for example let's try installing a
package and i can say apt get installed
vim
or app get installed wget or
apt-get install open ssh
and all these packages are already
existing so not an issue
now i can start using this instance i
can just look at the disc
what is available okay now we gave
around 10 gigabyte
out of which we see 8.3 gigabyte here
for the dev sda1 and then 1.8 gigabyte
available
and you can continue using this machine
this was the easiest way
of connecting to a vm instance using ssh
now what we can also do is i can just
leave this
and i will now try to connect using an
external ssh client
right and here you can copy the public
ip
so when you want to connect to an
instance you will have to get the public
ip
also remember that if you select
and stop this machine which will stop
your billing counter
and if you start it again the internal
ip will remain same
but the external ip is the one which
will change
i can obviously select this machine
anytime and i can do a cleanup and i can
delete it
i can do a start of the machine if it is
stopped
and i can even import the virtual
machine to be used later so there are
different options which you can
always use so this is my instance
and if you would want to look at the
details click on this one
c1 and that should basically allow you
to look at the details
so it shows you what is the instance id
what is the machine type
is it reservation specific what is the
cpu platform what's the zone
and all the other details at any point
of time if you would want to edit
you can always click on edit and you can
change the details
as you need now you can also look at the
equivalent rest command
to basically use the rest api to connect
to this instance for now
i have copied the public ip and i would
want to connect it using putty
so let's go in here and let's give it
the host name
so i can give ubuntu i can give my ip
address
so that's in my session now i will click
on ssh
i would go into authentication i'll
click on browse
and this is where i need to choose the
ppk
file so this is the one which we created
new key let's select this
and then i can come back to session i
can even save this
and i can call it as my instance
one let's save it and you can create any
number of instances so you see
i have created different instances here
for my google cloud or amazon
related instances and i can click on
open it says
the service host key is not cached in
the registry that's fine just click on
yes
and basically it says no authentication
method supported now this could be
because
we have not enabled your ssh access so
let's look at that
so now let's see if we were trying to
connect using putty
what was the issue here so if i go back
to
my putty select my instance
load it it says port 22 i am giving the
username which is ubuntu
or sorry that's the wrong username we
gave and that might be the reason
we had set up the user as sdu so let's
save this again
and now let's try connecting to this one
and it asks for my password
and you are able to connect this right
now if there was any other issue related
to network connectivity then we could
look at the rules
the inbound and outbound rules which
allow us to look into the machine
now we are connected to our machine here
using hdu user i can log in as root
and i can continue working so not only
from the ssh
within the cloud console but you can use
an external ssh client and connect to
your machine
so this is your ubuntu machine and we
can basically
look at the space and that basically
confirms we are connecting to the same
machine
which shows 8.3 gigabytes here and 1.8
gigabytes here which we were seeing from
the
ssh in the browser now let's close this
and let's go back to our instance page
now here
you can always look at the network
details and this will show you
your different kind of rules that is
ingress or egress rules
which basically allows to connect to
this machine from an external network
or for this machine to connect to an
external network
so here we have different firewall rules
which shows default allow
http that's your ingress rule and
it tells you apply to all it shows me
what are the ip ranges where i can
specifically give the ip of my machine
it shows the protocols it shows what are
the different ports which you have used
for these services for example rtp or
ssh which shows 22
you have icmp http and https
now anytime if you would want to make a
change to these rules
that can be done by going into your
network details
and say for example you would want to
work
on firewall rules so we have these
firewall rules here you can click on
this one so right now we are looking
into the network
domain and we are looking into vpc
network right
and this shows me what are the different
rules we have
now if i would want to create a
different firewall rule for a different
protocol
i can always click on create firewall
rule i can give it a name
okay i can say what if you would want to
turn on the firewall logs
you can basically say what is the kind
of traffic so ingress applies to
incoming traffic
and egress applies to outgoing traffic
and you can then basically choose what
are the ip ranges from where you want
that connection to be coming in
or to going out you can choose a
particular protocol
you can give a protocol here with comma
separated values and you can create a
firewall rule
so this might be required depending on
the services
which you are running wherein you might
want to
enable your access to your machine from
an external service or to an external
service so you can always go to network
details
from here you can then go into firewall
rules create a firewall rule
apply that to your instance and restart
your instance
so as of now we don't need to create any
network details
here because my ingress or egress rules
are already available
right now i can basically then have my
instance stopped and removed so i can
just do a stop
or since this is running the ideal wave
would be to do a stop
i could also do a reset now what does
reset do reset does not
basically delete the machine what it
does is it does a cleanup of the machine
and it brings it to the initial state so
sometimes we might have installed
certain things on our machine we would
want to clean them up
and at that time reset can be useful i
can basically click on delete
right and i can select this and i can do
a cleanup and
this is good always when you are using a
free trial account
try to use different services play
around with them
and then you can clean up so that you do
not waste your free billing
credit right and you can use it for
meaningful stuff
now i have clicked on delete and within
few seconds my
instance which i had created will be
deleted
also to remember is if you are creating
multiple instances
then you can connect from one machine to
other machine using
ssh by using the private file so
for that we can learn in detail later
so this is just a simple example of
using your compute engine
creating your instances connecting to it
from an
internal ssh or from an external ssh
client such as putty
where you have already created your
private and public
keys now i can click on the browser here
and then i can basically come out and i
can basically be looking into any
particular service so we just looked
into
compute engine right you have different
other options you have instance groups
you have instance templates for example
let's click on instance templates here
and that basically shows you that you
don't have any instance template
and this basically facilitates say for
example you are working as a admin
and you would want to create an instance
template so that using that
you can describe a vm instance and then
you can basically use this template to
create
different instances you can go for
sultenant nodes
you can look for machine images you can
also look at your disks
you can create a snapshots and you can
look at different options here
now let's come back here and let's click
on home
and that should take you back to your
home page which basically shows you
if a particular api which you have used
recently which shows me in the graph
here
so i can go to the api's overview right
and that basically shows me if there
were any errors
if i was using the compute engine api to
basically create
a vm instance and that's why we were
seeing some spike in the graph
so this is a quick demo of using your
compute
engine service provided by google cloud
wherein you can create
vm instances and use those vm instances
for your application installation
for any other purpose now that we have
seen
how you use your cloud console to create
an instance and also clean it up
let's also understand how you can do
using your command line
options and let's see what it takes or
what are the different commands which
you can use to create your
instances now you can always
when when you're creating an instance
you can
use compute engine which provisions
resources to start the instance
so instance basically has different
states
which we can see when we are creating
the instance
so you basically start the instance
instance
moves into staging that is prepared for
your first boot
finally it boots up and then it moves
into
running so when you look at instant
states which we will create instance and
see
it will basically have different states
such as provisioning
where resources are being allocated for
instance but instances
not yet running then it goes into
staging
where resources have been acquired an
instance is being prepared for your
first boot
then instance is booting up and running
and if you are stopping an instance it
goes into
being stop status and it would be moved
to the
terminated option you can also do a
repairing
of instance and finally you can
terminate your instance
or clean it up by stopping and then
deleting it
now when you say stopping and resetting
an instance you can stop the instance
as i showed earlier if you no longer
need it but if you need for future use
you can just use the reset option which
will basically wipe the contents of
instance
or any application state and then
finally you can
stop it and have it terminated
now when you would want to do that using
your cloud console
or we have seen the options now let's
also see from the command line tool
how you can do it so here i have the
cloud shell which i brought up
from here and i basically opened it in a
new window
so command line tool enables you to
easily manage your
compute engine resources in a friendlier
format
than using your compute engine api
now gcloud which is part of cloud sdk
is the main command here and then you
can
always auto complete the different
options here
so when you would want to create or
work on gcloud you can just type in
gcloud here
and then for example i could just say
help to see different options of g cloud
which will show me different options
which you can use here now we would be
interested in
compute instances so i could also do a g
cloud compute
compute instances and then
i can basically say create and then i
can
do a help now that should show me
different options which work with
gcloud compute instances create command
which is expecting
an instance name so your google cloud
sdk
which we can set up on our windows
machine or even on your linux machine
is set of tools that helps you to manage
resources and applications
hosted on your gcp that is your google
cloud platform
now here you have options such as gcloud
which i am showing you right now you
have gsutil
and then you have bq so that also can be
used
so you can set up a google cloud compute
if using gcloud now what we can do
is if we are setting up
our sdk on our windows machine then we
would have to do a gcloud init
which basically initializes your
configurations for g
cloud now here we are using a cloud
shell
which was started from the console and
we don't have to
basically give your g cloud init command
because it's already initialized
now you can always look at your default
zone
you can look at your region what is
being used all those things
are coming from the metadata which is
being used
so for example i could be looking at
the metadata for my particular project
by just doing a g cloud and then i can
say
compute and i would be interested in
project info
so i can just do a project minus info
and then i can do a describe and then
i need my project id so i can say minus
minus project
and i can get my project id from here so
you can click on this one
and that's my project id so i can click
on this one
and here i can just do a right click
and if it does not paste then you can do
a
ctrl v and then i can try to look at my
project info
so this basically will give me the
metadata which is by default
set and we can always look at what are
the regions
or what is the zone which has been set
so
if it has been set so i'm looking at my
details it is showing me my ssh keys
and then it can be using your default
region
and your default available zones it also
shows my username
and other details so this is basically
to look at the metadata which is
available
now at any point of time i can basically
say
add metadata i can basically choose
metadata option
and i can say my default region
should be europe which i was choosing
earlier so i can just bring up this
command again
and what i can do is i can say here
where i have gcloud compute project info
where i did it described
earlier now what i could also do is i
can just say
add metadata and then
i can specify what is the metadata i
would be interested in adding
i can then say google compute
default region and then
i can basically give a region for
example europe
and then i can say west 3
and if you are not well experienced you
can always do it from
console or you can be doing it from here
so i'm giving google cloud compute
google compute default region then i can
also give
a google compute default zone
and then i can pass in a value for
default zone so i can say europe west 3
and then basically i can give an
availability zone
so if it is basically giving me some
error where i am trying to
pass in these values so i can just give
it this way
and then it basically says that if you
can
look into particular help to see what is
the command
which you would have to do now i can
basically do a g
cloud init here initial configuration
and this basically says that it is
initializing
my default configuration it says
reinitialize this configuration from
cloud shell
you want to create a new configuration
so if i had
updated my metadata
then basically i could just do a cloud
init
and i could be re-initializing my
default configuration or properties
which i have passed in
so as of now i will not activate or
change the default region let's go for a
simple
way in which you can create your compute
engine so for example i'll just say one
and it is re-initializing
it asks me what is the username and
let's select that
it says what is the project and let's
select that
and do you want to configure a default
compute region
and zone right and i will just say yes
and basically then it shows me different
options which we have here
so there are too many options here and
then here
we were interested in europe west 3 so
let's choose
21 right and then that basically allows
me
to choose my region and my zone
so it also gives you some specification
so it says your project default compute
zone has been set to
europe s3 a you can change it by running
gcloud
config set and you can give a compute
zone
right so i can always give these
commands i can get
help information here so i can just say
gcloud
config set and i can be
specifying the compute zone so i can say
compute slash zone
and i can give a zone i can say compute
slash region
and i can give a region name if i would
want to do it or the easier way is like
what i did right now
so you can basically do a command
gcloud in it and then basically it
allows you to
change your configuration or set default
things here you cannot all the times
you can say gcloud config unset
to basically remove a compute zone
or a compute region now there are
different ways so if you were
working on a linux machine you could
always
use an export command something like
this so you could do export
compute sorry cloud sdk
and then you can say compute underscore
zone and then give your zone name or
compute underscore region
and give your region or you could add it
in your bash rc
file right now that is when you have
your cloud sdk setup on your linux
machine
or on windows machine and you would want
to specifically set a
zone and a region for all your compute
related
resources so we don't need to do that
the default settings are already given
here
right and what we can do is we can start
by quickly looking into gcloud
compute instances options so i can say
gcloud
compute instances
and then i can just do a list at any
point of time
if you would need help you can just do a
gcloud compute
and then say minus minus help or i could
just do a gcloud compute
and that shows me different options
which i have here from which
i use instances i can always type
instances and again hit enter
and it shows me different options what
you would want to do
so i can initially just type list which
should show me
what are the list or what are the
instances available
and as of now we don't have any
instances
i can always do a list and then
i can specify minus minus format
and then try to get the information in a
json format or ml
or minus minus format text
so you can always do a list you can do a
filter
so there are different options with your
list and you can
you can try doing a help here and that
basically shows you what are the options
so for example if i do a help and it
shows me with list
what are the things you can do so you
can give a name
you can give a regular expression you
can say in particular zone
you can use a minus filter so there are
different commands which are available
and you can always find all those
options here
as i showed you earlier so now what we
would be
interested in is basically going for
your compute instances i can always do a
ssh
and i can create an instance i can add
and remove metadata
right for my instances by giving a
particular
zone by giving a particular region and
if you would want to do that now here
what we can do is we can basically
create
an instance by just giving a name to
that particular instance and
we can then go back to our console and
see what has it done
so i can say here create
so that's an option let's see what does
the create do
so it says okay you are giving a create
option but you would have to give a name
so let's say let's call it e1 and that
will be the name of my instance
and this one is an easy command from
your cloud shell
which basically creates an instance you
see the zone which has been set
it is the standard machine type it is
not preemptable
it has an internal ip and it has an
external
ip now i have created an instance
and here i can just go back
and then i can just do a refresh on this
page and that
already shows me the instance which i
have created
and then you can use the same method to
connect to it using an ssh
so i have an instance created from my
cloud shell
and what i can do is i can basically
look into instances and see what are the
different options with instance
so if we did a create right you have an
option delete
we did a create you have an option
delete you can be
then deleting the instance from the
command line or you can use
other options so you can do a list you
can do a stop
you can start so i can basically do a
stop
and let's say even let's go ahead and do
a stop
commands are pretty easy here to
remember or you can always use the help
option
and now i'm trying to stop the instance
and then basically
i can go ahead and delete it so this is
a simple way
where i created a instance
from the command line or from the
console which i showed earlier
and similarly you can be working with
other options
so now i've created stop the instance
let's do a listing to see
if my instance shows up it shows up
right and it says the status is
terminated
so you have stopped it it's in the
terminated status
and now what i can do is i can go ahead
and delete it
so it says this will be lost are you
sure you would want to continue
just say yes and that should take care
of deleting your instance
so this is a quick demo on creating your
instance we have already seen how you
can
connect to these instances using ssh
now that we have created instances
let's also see how to use google cloud's
storage
service which can be used to load data
or upload data so for this we will have
to
look into your google cloud storage
options
and here you can look in cloud storage
so let's go back here on the top
which shows me different services which
we have here
and let's look into storage so this one
shows me
your storage option now you can click on
browser and that basically shows me your
storage browser which shows me on the
top
you have options for creating a bucket
now google cloud storage allows you to
store any kind of data here
the easiest and the simplest way would
be by using cloud console
although you can again use cloud shell
and in that you can use your
gsutil command and gsutil basically
has different options where you can be
using say for example i would want to
work on buckets
so i can be using mb and then i can use
my command line option to create buckets
i can put in data there i can browse it
and i can access the data from
command line so let's create a bucket
here
let's click on this let's give it a name
so let's say my
data important that's the name
now i can click on continue straight
away i can look into all of these
options if i'm interested in so you can
basically be looking at your monthly
cost estimate
in the beginning now i can click on
continue or you can say
choose where to store your data and this
one shows you
different options so you have region
specific
so let's also give the bucket name with
all lower case
that's what is required yeah so coming
back to the location type
you can choose multi region which
basically allows high availability
so your bucket or your storage option
will be accessible
across regions you can also give dual
region
and high availability and low latency
across two regions
i can also say region specific so for
our use case we can just give region
specific
which can keep our costs low but in
business use cases you would be going
for multi-region
now here you have location and i would
again
go for say europe and let's choose
europe west 3 frankfurt
it is always a good practice that when
you create your instances when you
create your storage
or you use different services try to
have
a geographical region chosen and then
you would try to
put things or your services within the
particular region within a particular
zone
unless you would want to make it
accessible and available across regions
now i can then choose a default storage
class
so when you say default storage class
there are different storage class and
each one
is for a different use case so you have
standard which is best for short-term
storage and frequently accessed data you
have near line
so this is basically best for backups
and data access less than
once a month you can also have cold
lines so these are basically
like your cold storage or freezing
storage which you might have heard
generically as terms so you can choose
one of these
storage classes depending on what will
be the use case for this particular
storage bucket so let it be standard now
how to control
access to objects so you can basically
say specify access to
individual objects by using object level
permissions
now you can give permissions to the
bucket
you can just say uniform access to all
objects in the bucket by using only
bucket level permissions so you can
choose that
you can also go into advanced settings
and here you can see
different ways in which you can have
configuration setup now you can also
have a retention policy to specify the
minimum duration
where that this bucket's object must be
protected
from deletion and you can set a
retention policy will not get into all
that
we will just first try creating a bucket
so just click on create and that should
create
your bucket wherein i have my
bucket now i can click on overview to
see the details what is the region
which region it belongs what is the
storage class
anytime you can always click on edit
bucket and make some changes here
you can look at the permissions so
bucket uses fine grained access
allowing you to specify access to
individual objects
and then you can basically look at
who has access to this so in my case
editors of the project they basically
are the bucket owners
owners of project viewers of the project
right
and you can basically choose what kind
of access you need
so for this you can always go into cloud
storage
and then you can decide what kind of
access you would want to give whether
that's a storage
admin it's an object admin object
creator object viewer and so on
you can always look at storage legacy
and
for any other services depending on what
apis you have enabled
right you can always control your
permissions so
right now it is storage legacy bucket
reader and that's fine
and this one is bucket owner and then
might be i was using some other services
like data proc which uses cloud storage
and that's why i have given data proc
service agent also
so these are some of the members you can
remove you can view by specific members
you can
view by roles so what are the different
roles which
have access to this so it says storage
legacy bucket owner
there are two owners based on this
particular project so these are
auto controlled but then you can add or
remove machines
you can save storage cost by adding a
life cycle rule to delete objects after
the duration of
current retention policy so you can add
different policies
and you can basically control your
bucket
now my bucket is already created right
so i can go back
and then i see my bucket is already here
i can
click on this option and you can anytime
edit the bucket permissions you can edit
the labels the default storage class
you can just go ahead and delete the
bucket you can export it to cloud pub
sub
so basically if you would want to have
the content from this bucket
being accessible in a message queuing
system
you can go for pub sub you can process
with cloud functions and you can scan
with cloud data loss prevention so there
are different options which are
available
we can always select this bucket and
delete it now i can click on the bucket
and that basically shows me different
ways in which i can
upload some data here so i can just
click on upload
files and here then i can choose some
files so for example i'll go in here
i'll go into data sets
and i have different data sets so for
example let's choose this one which is a
csv
file and then i'm just uploading this to
my cloud storage
right it's as simple as this so you can
drag and drop your files
or you can just upload your files and my
file is uploaded here
now i can basically edit permissions for
this one
right so this is in the bucket so anyone
who has access to this bucket
can basically download this file it can
they can copy move or rename this you
can export it
and you can look at the permissions of
this file so let's look at edit
permissions
and it says for this project whoever is
the owner
it has access i've also given a specific
user my gmail id
and i've given access so at any point of
time you can just say
add item and then you can start giving
different kind of accesses so let's
click on cancel here
now my data is already uploaded into
this particular bucket
and that's a simple usage of
your cloud storage now what we can also
do
is i can basically select this
and i can delete it i can also create
specific folders
and then basically load data into it
i can click on this one i can just do a
download
and then i can download it anywhere on
my machine so let's go to desktop
and let's download this file so we not
only uploaded some content in the bucket
but we also downloaded that in a
different location which
will be accessible now what i could have
also done
is i could have created a folder here
and i could have specified
say for example immediate immediate
data okay and
i'm clicking on this one so that's my
immediate data i can click on this one
and now i can upload my data
specifically
to this particular folder by using the
same mechanism
you can just do upload file let's choose
air passengers
let's do a open and my file will be
uploaded
so you can always choose what is the
retention
expiry date for this one so as of now
there is nothing
right but you can be deleted objects can
be deleted or modified
until there is a minimum duration you
can control all of that
you can basically download it right you
can copy it
and you can move it and rename it so
this is a simple example
where i created a particular bucket
right
now if for example you click on this
transfer so it says cloud storage data
transfer products have moved
you can now find storage transfer
service on premise data and transfer
appliance in new data transfer section
right so you can always go back to cloud
storage
you can also look at transfer options
which are mainly when you are
using an on-premise service and you
would want to upload data
in a google cloud right so this is
my bucket here now i can go to cloud
console
and here what i can do is if i would be
interested in working so i can just say
gsutil
right and then we have for example let's
try a help
okay and that basically shows me my
gsutil now you can always go to quick
start gsutil tool
and this is one more way wherein
basically you can do it from the command
line
so working with buckets so you can do a
gsu till mb
minus b and then on a particular zone if
you would be interested in
and then you can say gs colon and give a
name so
my awesome bucket this is how you will
create a bucket
which will show you it is creating a
bucket and then basically you can upload
an
image or some data from internet
you can just do a wget download the file
and then you can just do a gsutil copy
command
and that basically will pick up the file
from your cloud shell location put it in
your bucket
once you have done that you can always
do a copy
right so here you are doing a copy from
your local machine
that is your cloud shell machine to your
bucket and you can do
the reverse of that that is you can do a
copy and you can
point your bucket and the file and
download it to your
desktops so you can just download that
using the command line
and you can copy the object to a folder
in the bucket
so that is by creating a particular
folder and you are pushing the file into
a particular bucket
you can list the contents of a bucket
using ls
and then give your bucket name so gs
colon so we can just try this one to be
simple
and rest you guys can try so here you
can just do a gsutil
you can do a ls gs colon
slash and then i need to give my
bucket name so in my case the bucket
name
was my data important so let's try that
so let's say my data important
and i'm trying to list the bucket and
the content it has
right and then you have a folder and
then you can look into the folder
and look into the files so this is a
simple
quick option when you can use your cloud
shell
you could be using your google cloud sdk
from your local machine
or you can be using cloud console to
create a bucket
upload some data on it download the data
see if the data is accessible
and that basically shows you the power
of cloud storage
where you can easily upload any kind of
data now
what we can also do is as you are using
a free account
or even a paid account unless and until
you would want to keep the bucket
you can select it and you can just go
ahead and delete it
so this will basically ask you to key in
the bucket name
and let's say my data important you need
to confirm your bucket name
click on confirm and you could have done
that using gsutil
and a delete command from the command
line that is from cloud shell
so we have now created a bucket we have
uploaded some data into it
we saw how you can download it or create
a folder and upload some specific data
into it
and also you can do the same thing using
gsutil
tools wherein you can list your bucket
create your buckets delete it
create some folders into it and do
everything from the command line
so this is in simple way you can use
your
gcp where either you can spin up your
machines
or you can use cloud storage to
basically
use a storage or a easy to use
instance on google cloud platform
welcome to this tutorial
about google cloud platform and here
we will learn about cloud computing what
is cloud computing
what is gcp that is your google cloud
platform
what are the benefits of google cloud
platform
and what are its different services a
little bit about google's infrastructure
a comparison
of different cloud providers such as
google
offering gcp that is google's cloud
platform
amazon offering amazon web services and
microsoft which offers azure we will
also learn about domino's pizza use case
and then have a quick demo on using
some of the services on gcp
before we begin let's understand why
cloud computing and it would be always
good
to learn about cloud computing based on
a use case there are varied use cases
where
organizations are adopting or
moving their solutions or their
infrastructure
into cloud or i can simply say
integrating with cloud now here is one
use case
nina started a company that relates to
website
development the
challenges which nina was facing were
low memory space
whenever required for processing or
for any other kind of application
related work
high traffic to website that crashed it
and also less number of servers
now with these challenges she was then
referred to
concept of cloud computing and how that
could benefit and help her in solving
her issues most of her issues were
solved when she started using cloud
computing and with cloud computing
she could increase her memory space
as required that is on demand control
the load to the website that is
basically load balancing and handling
more requests on the website or requests
per minute
buying servers at a lower price
that is scaling up or down based on the
requirement
when we talk about cloud computing cloud
computing
is use of hardware and software
components which a cloud provider offers
as a service which can be accessed over
network
cloud computing is use of these
resources
which could be either dedicated
resources or coming from a pool
of resources which cloud provider offers
to
deliver a service to clients
users can access these different
services
applications files from any device
which can basically access internet
cloud computing allows automatic
software integration
it allows backing up and restoring of
data
it basically offers unlimited storage
memory
or computation capacity
it gives access to reliable sources
which
usually the cloud provider themselves
are
using for their use case
and it is a cost efficient model
which helps organizations to quickly
integrate or basically modernize their
infrastructure cloud computing is
usually
used with id or
within id space wherein there are five
traits
if there is a requirement of resources
as the business dynamically changes or
grows
so for this cloud computing offers
on-demand self-service
so users could be using on-demand
computing resources
or memory resources storage network
and so on provided by cloud provider and
also
do a self-service all this is possible
using a simple interface
and users can be using processing power
storage
network as they need and pay as they go
so there is least or no human
intervention required
when it comes to projects which might
need
scalable network access cloud computing
offers broad
network access that is accessing
resources over network
across geographical regions or what we
call as
availability zones which might be
multiple sites within a particular
geographical region
cloud providers also have what we call
as a resource pooling
so this basically provides a huge pool
of resources which are shared and
can be accessed by customers at a lower
cost now there might be customers which
are interested in
not sharing the resources and would be
interested in dedicated
resources and in this case cloud
provider also have
sole tenant offerings which help such
customers
if an it business or any other business
needs
rapid elasticity then cloud providers
also have resources which are offered
which are elastic
you can get more resources rapidly as
needed
and thus you can scale up and down think
of a gaming
company which would be interested in
launching a new game
and they would have predicted a certain
number of users which would get on to
the portal
playing the game and what happens if the
request per minute or if the number of
users who are joining in
might increase now in this case
organization would want
an underlying solution which handles
this dynamism
scales as needed on demand
and once the demand is done scales down
this is possible using a cloud computing
solution
cloud computing solutions also include
measured services that is pay as you go
model
for the usage or for the reservations
which
a user or organization would have made
for
resources offered by cloud computing so
when we talk about cloud computing one
of the question which always arises
is why is this model so compelling
why is this so interesting for
organizations or
users who would want to use one or many
services from cloud computing
so first wave of trend which brought
storage cloud computing was
what we call as colo that is co-location
i.t shops that have been using
or managing huge amount of data from
tickets
basically wanted to build their
infrastructures
to handle their business needs now
instead of building costlier data
centers
they would rent space or share
facilities and this was being done by
organizations
even in past thus they would free up
the capital for other use cases now
this was more of user configured managed
and maintained
by them later organizations started
thinking of virtualization
so that was again user configured but
provider managed and maintained so
components of a virtualized data center
matched that of a physical data center
and organizations would have virtual
devices
separately managed from underlying
devices
then later came container based
architectures
or basically automated services
so within google services are
automatically provisioned
and configured letting your
infrastructure scale
on demand there are various reasons why
an organization
would think of integrating with cloud
or benefiting by using cloud
and thus instantaneously
reaping the benefits of modernizing
their infrastructure
now few famous cloud providers are here
so you have amazon which offers amazon
web services
and a huge list of services
which come in with this you have
microsoft's azure
you have oracle's cloud you have saps
cloud solutions
gcp which is offered by google
salesforce and so on there are many
other small players
which are also providing different
services which are cloud-based
or organizations which are partnering
with these
main cloud providers thus offering cloud
services to their customers
when we talk about why google cloud
platform
there are various reasons why someone
would choose google cloud platform
gcp has better pricing compared to its
competitors
when it comes to speed and performance
it is very fast
and increases the performance of the
project
live migration of apps and there are
huge number of solutions
which i will show you further in further
screens
which help an organization to adopt
to a cloud platform an integrated with
cloud platform or even completely
migrate
into a cloud platform none of
google's competitors provide live
migration of apps
when we talk about big data ai machine
learning kind of solutions
gcp provides a lot of innovative
solutions
in comparison to other cloud providers
such as aws
azure and so on
so what is google cloud platform it has
a set of cloud computing services
provided by google that runs on the same
infrastructure that google uses to
and for its end user products like
youtube
gmail and so on
let's learn about benefits of google
cloud platform
such as high productivity working from
anywhere
quick collaboration high security
fewer data stored on vulnerable devices
reliable resources which can be used
across organization across geographical
regions
across countries very flexible which
allows
organizations to scale up and down as
the demand rises are as the demand
declines
and cost effective solutions for various
use cases these are some of the benefits
and if we look into different services
which google cloud platform
offers we could look into detailed
benefits which each service offers in
a different use case which basically
helps
organizations working in different
domains
handling different kind of small mid or
larger businesses
and with different business goals
when we talk about google cloud platform
services here
is a list of services or i could say
high level domains or categories of
services
so you have compute related services you
have storage and database
you have networking big data developer
tools
identity and security management
internet of things
cloud ai management tools and
also data transfer solutions
when we talk about google's
infrastructure google has one of the
most
powerful infrastructure in the world the
infrastructure is available in two
levels the physical and the abstract
layers
you have physical infrastructure and
then you have the
abstract infrastructure physical
infrastructure
consists of data centers extensive
development of high efficiency back-end
data centers
you have a very strong backbone network
which is
used by google itself and also offered
as services to customers via gcp
platform services
so you have global messed redundant
backbone network points of presence
when we talk about google it has 110
plus
edge points of presence in more than 200
countries
and when we talk about edge caching edge
caching platform
at periphery of their network so this
is what defines the physical
infrastructure of google
now there is much more to it rather than
just these four points
when we talk about abstract
infrastructure that is divided in global
regions and zones when we talk about
zone a zone is roughly equivalent to a
data center
and a single point of failure so you
could have your compute engine
which is within a zone or you could say
compute engine is a zonal resource
you have regions which are geographical
areas which contain multiple zones
so you would have a region for u.s
central
or europe central europe west
and so on and within a region you would
have
one or multiple zones and zones
basically would
allow high availability of resources
so you have cloud load balancer is an
example which is
regional resource then you have global
resources
and they are available and shared across
the planet
so you have various global resources
such as network
which could be even your ip addresses
and so on
now let's do a quick comparison of aws
with azure wes gcp
and let's look at what each cloud
provider offers
later we will also look into different
services
in detail when it comes to google cloud
platform
what each service does what you can
benefit from
which service should you use in what
case we will learn about those
in later slides if i compare
your different cloud providers
when we talk about amazon and its
cloud offerings that is amazon web
services or aws as we well
know it amazon web services has 69
availability zones within 22
geographical locations
and soon it will have 12 more in future
so this number keeps growing based on
the spread of the services which a
particular cloud provider
offers here we are talking about
availability zone
specific information when we talk about
microsoft's azure
it has 54 regions worldwide
and is available in 140 countries across
the globe
when we talk about google cloud google
cloud platform is available in 200 plus
countries
across the globe when we talk about
virtual servers
amazon's ec2 that is elastic compute
cloud
it is a web service which basically
helps to resize your compute capacity
where you can run your application
programs on a virtual machine
so using ec2 service you could
launch virtual instances that would have
any distribution of linux windows
you could have different specifications
when it comes to ram
or cpu cores or disk you could also
decide
on what kind of storage a particular
instance should use
whether the storage should be local to
the instance or whether that should be a
elastic
file system or even an object storage
when it comes to azure or microsoft's
offering
as your virtual machine that is
infrastructure
as a service gives a user the ability to
deploy and manage a virtual environment
inside
a virtual network on the cloud
and this virtual network on the cloud
would be managed
by cloud provider google cloud
or the offerings from google cloud
platform that is gcp vm instances
enables users to build deploy and manage
virtual machines
in order to run different kind of
workloads on the cloud
now when we talk about compute engine
here it would be good
to discuss a little bit more about
compute
engine and what are the different
options which
google cloud offers so when you talk
about your compute
engine you have scalable
high performance virtual machines
compute engine delivers
configurable virtual machines which run
in google's data center
with access to high performance
networking infrastructure
and block storage and you could select
vms
for your needs that could be general
purpose or workload optimized
and when we talk about workload
optimized you have predefined
machines or you have custom machine
sizes
you can integrate compute with other
google cloud services such as
ai or ml and go for your data analytics
you have when we talk about your gcp vm
instances just to expand on that
you have general purpose instances which
we call as
n2 which provide a balance between price
and performance
and they are well suited for most
workloads including line of business
applications
web servers and databases google cloud
also offers compute
optimized instances which we call as c2
instances which offer consistent
high-end
virtual cpu performance which are good
for
aaa gaming eda
hpc and other applications now
when we talk about compute optimize your
general purpose
how would we leave memory optimized
instances those are m2 machines
which google offers so these offer
highest amount of memory
these vms are well suited for in-memory
databases such as sap hana real-time
analytics and in-memory caches
so if i would summarize this when we
talk about
different instances aws
also offers different kind of instances
which are
memory or compute or
disk optimized you have general purpose
and
each category of machines has a
different pricing model
you can always go to an aws website look
for the pricing models
and that will give you an idea of
on-demand instances
or dedicated instances reserved
instances and so on
similarly if you talk about google cloud
google cloud also has instances with
various
options which become the key features of
why
customers would choose google cloud
platform such as live migration for vms
so compute engine within your gcp
can live migrate between host systems
and when i say live migrate
it basically means without rebooting
which keeps your application running
even when the underlying host systems
require maintenance
you also have preemptable virtual
machines
wherein you can run bad jobs and fault
tolerant
workloads on pre-emptible vms to reduce
your virtual cpu and memory cost by up
to 80 percent while getting the same
performance
so these are your preemptive or
preemptable virtual machines the only d
minute
is these can give you a really cost
efficient resource usage however
can be taken off the shelf anytime
and that's why we call them preemptable
virtual machines
you also have sole tenant nodes which
are physical compute
engine servers dedicated explicitly
or exclusively for users
use case and when we talk about sole
tenant nodes these are usually good
when you are dealing with or when you're
working with your applications which we
call as
bring your own license applications so
sole tenant nodes
give you access to same machine types
and virtual machine config options
as regular compute instances so there
are different options which google cloud
offers
when it comes to these instances which
we are talking about
and it takes care of different use cases
in comparison to
other cloud providers which are also
offering these
services such as you can have
pre-defined machine types you can have
custom machine types
preemptable vms as i said live migration
of vms
you can use persistent disks
which could give you durable high
performance block storage
you have local ssds you also have gpu
accelerators which can be added to
accelerate computational
intensive workloads such as machine
learning simulation
medical analysis and so on and you have
features such as global load balancing
which
makes google cloud a unique choice
when we talk about platform as a service
amazon has
platform as a service offering which we
call as elastic bean stock
among one of its services it's an
orchestration service for deploying
applications and helping in maintaining
these applications
azure cloud service provides a platform
to write the user application code
without worrying about the hardware
resources
google app engine is a service used by
developers for building and hosting
applications on google's
data centers when we talk about
server-less computing
so amazon's aws lambda
is a server-less compute service it is
used to execute back-end code
and scales automatically when required
when we talk about azure you have
something called as functions which
allow users
to build applications using server-less
symbol functions with a programming
language of their choice
when we talk about google cloud gcp has
cloud functions
which is easiest way to run your code in
the cloud
and it is highly available and fault
tolerant
so in these days when we are talking
about microservices architecture which
organizations are preferring
when we are talking about organizations
which can scale
which can dynamically change their
underlying architecture
organizations would be interested in
server less computing
where they do not have to have a
infrastructure
setup planned in advance before going
for their use case
and this is where monolithic
applications
are really not a preferred choice
a lot of organizations are decomposing
their
applications into microservices based on
business capability or decomposing based
on sub domains we can learn about
microservices architecture later
but just to know that serverless
computing
which basically helps any organization
if for example if you have a web
application that receives
non-linear traffic and you cannot keep
an eye
on your server always it would be good
to have someone to auto scale
your application serverless is basically
a computing model
where cloud service provider is
responsible
for managing the piece of code without
the developer having to bother about
infrastructure
setup management maintenance and so on
now when we talk about applications
being serverless or benefiting from
serverless computing one of the key
things would be
zero administration so deploying
application without
any provisioning and management auto
scaling capability
that is let the service provider worry
about
scaling the application up and down you
have paper use model
which any customer would want to benefit
from that is
pay only for the resources that you have
used
or that you are continuing to use
right shorten the time between idea
implementation and employment and this
is something which any organization
would want
that you would want a faster
bring to the market solution timeline in
comparison to
getting entangled with deployment
management and maintenance of your
underlying infrastructure
when your applications are facing a high
demand
so when we talk about serverless it is a
function as a service
because each part of your application is
divided as functions
and can be hosted over multiple service
providers
you have serverless apps which are
usually divided as separate units
or functions based on functionalities or
domains
and so on so serverless computing is
gaining quite popularity
these days in comparison to the
traditional three-tier
architecture where you had a
presentation layer
you had an application layer you had a
database layer now that kind of
infrastructure is not really preferred
in today's modern times when
organizations
are working on different kind of newer
applications when we talk about object
storage
amazon has simple storage service that
is s3
it provides object storage which is
built for storing and recovering
information or data from anywhere over
the internet
azure comes up with blob storage that is
binary large objects
storage offers large amount of storage
and scalability
it stores the object in the tiers and
depending on
how often the data is being accessed now
same thing applies to
even s3 which is from amazon
so s3 also has different kind of storage
classes
which can be selected when a user or
organization intends to use a storage
service
and when i speak about storage classes
it basically means
having a frequent access storage or a
infrequent access storage or what we
call
as just an archival solution
google cloud has cloud storage and it
provides unified
object storage for live or archive data
this service is used to store and access
data on gcp
infrastructure when it comes to
advantages
amazon web services has enterprise
friendly services
easy access to resources increase in
speed
and agility and that too on demand and
takes care of your security and
reliability of resources which are
offered
when it comes to azure it has better
development operations
strong security profile provides lot of
cost effective solutions
and operation execution friendly
when we talk about google cloud one of
the key features here is
better pricing than competitors live
migration of virtual machines which
really
interests lot of organizations would
want to
modernize their infrastructure without
having
any kind of disruption in their existing
services
improved performance redundant backups
and so on
when it comes to disadvantages in aws
you have limitations when it comes to
ec2 service
well there are different options in the
kind of machines which you can choose
which you can work on you have a
technical support fee
which is incurred network connectivity
and then also downtime which
might be in case when you're migrating
azure
it has different code base for cloud and
premise
platform as a service ecosystem is not
really as efficient as infrastructure
as a service poor management of gui and
tools
integrated backup when we talk about
google cloud
support fee is quite hefty it depends on
what kind of solution or support you
would or organization would be
interested
in it has a complex pricing schema
although it has different use cases
for which any user or any organization
can benefit from
downloading data from google cloud
services is an
expensive option storage might not be
however
uploading data or downloading data would
be
an expensive option
when we talk about domino's pizza use
case now
while we were discussing about these
features i would
really want to spend more time in
discussing each of these features or
services
in detail such as you have compute
engine you have storage
you have big table you have data proc
and so on so there are huge list of
services now before we get into
your domino's pizza use case let me show
you this page on google cloud
where you can look at different services
so
if you go to cloud.google.com and if you
look at
get started option under dock so here
you can find build solutions look at
different use cases
learn from basics of what is your
google cloud what are cloud basics then
you can look at
different cloud products so here you
have products in different categories
such as ai and machine learning
api management compute containers data
analytics databases developer tools and
so on
and you can always click on
any one of these to look into different
solutions which are being offered what
are the different use cases
what are the best practices when it
comes to migrating vms to compute engine
or operating containers or building
containers and so on
you can always look at featured products
and that gives you
a quick snapshot of what are the
different products such as you have
compute
engine you have cloud run big query
which is a data warehouse
you have cloud sql which is a managed
mysql or postgres
you have cloud storage to basically push
in any kind of data there
you have security key enforcement ai and
machine learning and so on
so you have different feature products
now if you scroll down
to the lower end of this page you can
again look at different solutions and
that would be really interesting to read
and learn from so you have
infrastructure modernization
you have application modernization you
have data management and so on so if i
look at
infrastructure modernization you could
basically look
at the solutions which google cloud
offers and
what it does when it comes to having
your
infrastructure modernized or benefiting
by
integrating with cloud and having
immediate
benefits of infrastructure modernization
you can look at different use cases what
they are doing
how google cloud really helps when it
comes to
migrating the workloads to a
cloud and how your different cloud
solutions such as vm migration
you have sap on google cloud vmware as a
service
and so on and you could learn from these
different solutions which are offered
you can also look at application
modernization
so not only infrastructure modernization
but organizations would also be
interested in re-looking
at their applications we looking at how
these applications
could be moved from monolithic to
microservices architecture
or how applications can benefit from
modernization
and cloud computing offerings so you
have again different use cases
here which talks about different
ways in which google cloud can help how
you can modernize
your applications how you can use
different solutions which google cloud
is offering now when you talk about
cloud computing services
you can always go into cloud.google.com
if you have created a free account then
you can just
log in and every user by default gets a
300
free credit so wherein they can try out
different products where they can use
different services so here if i click on
console
where i'm already logged in with my
gmail account
or my google cloud account wherein i
have
300 free credit out of which some is
being used
you have a google cloud console and here
from the hamburger menu you can click
and you can look at different services
within different domains so you have
compute domain
which has different services such as app
you have compute
engine and that basically allows you to
use your
vm instances which we were talking about
previous slides
different instance groups create your
templates use sole tenant nodes
create snapshots or backup of your data
use different zones you can go for
kubernetes which is containerized based
engine you have cloud functions you have
cloud run
and then you have storage related
different options such as big table
you have data store fire store file
store storage and so on
and for each of these services you can
read about from the google's
documentation or anyways i will be
explaining that
later you can also look at networking
related
operation related and other tools which
are offered by google cloud so these are
huge list of services which google cloud
platform
offers in different ways for different
use cases
now let's look at this domino's pizza
use case and see what it
helps us learn about so you can always
access this page
by going to this link which talks about
customers
and then which shows you different use
cases
so domino's increasing monthly revenue
by six percent with google analytics
premium
google tag manager and google bigquery
so this is basically when domino's
started using gcp
and what was the result of that now
let's look further into this
so we all know that domino is
most popular pizza delivery chain
operating across the globe but how was
that possible let's take a look
so the challenges were they wanted to
integrate
marketing measurement across various
devices
connecting crm and digital data to
create a clear view
of customer behavior to make
cross-channel marketing performance
analysis easy and efficient
now for these challenges which domino's
was
facing the solution was using google
analytics premium
google tag manager and bigquery which
were used to integrate digital data
sources and crm
data reporting was made easier and more
efficient by implementing google
analytics premium
because it had the ability to access a
single google
analytics account to evaluate web
and app performance by using
the new google tag manager
implementation
dominos were able to act fast
they were able to connect crm data with
digital analytics
which basically provided domino with
greater visibility on
customer behavior what was the result
there was an immediate six percent
increase in monthly revenue
eighty percent of costs and ad serving
and operations were saved
increases agility with streamlined tag
management
they obtained easy access to powerful
reporting and customized dashboards
now that was just one simple use case
before we go on to hands-on we can also
talk a little bit
back about the services which
google cloud offers as we discussed
and some of these services which can
really make you
think why not google cloud
platform so when we talk about your
different
cloud platform services let's learn
about some of these services in brief in
what
each service is what it does and how
it can help us in handling our use cases
or working with
different products so let's learn
briefly about
different services which google cloud
platform offers
now one of the domains is compute and
then let's look at the compute services
which gcp offers now here i can log into
the console
and this hamburger menu on the top left
corner
i can click on this one and go into the
compute engine section
so this is the compute domain which has
app engine
kubernetes engine cloud functions and
cloud run
so these are your different services
which are offered within the compute
domain
and here we can get into compute engine
by clicking on this one
and then basically going to vm instances
so before we
see how we can use this compute engine
let's understand about some of the
features of compute engine which
basically offers scalable
high performance virtual machines which
are configurable
and which runs in google's data center
with access to high performance
networking infrastructure and block
storage
so from here you can select vm for your
needs
for your general purpose or workload
optimized
predefined or custom machines now
here you can integrate compute with
other google cloud services such as ai
ml and other data analytics services you
have different machines which are
offered here
such as general purpose which provide a
balance between price and performance
which are well suited for most workloads
including line of business applications
web services
and databases you also have compute
optimized machines
which offer consistent high end virtual
cpu core performance
and which are mainly good for gaming eda
high process computing and other such
applications
apart from general purpose compute
optimized
you also have memory optimized machines
which offer highest amount of memory
and these vms are basically well suited
for
in-memory databases such as sap hana
real-time analytics
and in-memory cache now we can see these
options here
you can click on vm instances while
you're logged in
into your google cloud console here you
can even create an
instance template which can be used to
spin up
instances for example if i click on new
vm instance from a template
there are some templates which i have
already created for my usage
now here i can basically use
one of these templates or what i can do
is i can go back i can go into instance
templates
and this basically allows me to create a
template so you can click on create
instance template which basically allows
you to create
templates which can be used to spin up
different instances we can give a name
to the template for example we can say
template
instance now here i can choose
machine configurations and this is where
you have different options
so you have general purpose as i
mentioned which provide a balance
between price and performance
you have memory optimized which are
large memory machine types for
memory intensive workloads you also have
compute optimized which basically give
you high performance machine types for
compute intensive workloads so you can
choose any machine configuration which
is
available here based on your
requirements now if you click on general
purpose
that has different options here so you
look into the series
where you have n1 series you have e2
which are cpu platform selection based
on availability
you have n2 and n2d so let's just have
n1 selected
now you also have here which talks about
machine types
and here we can choose the configuration
which we are interested
in depending on the applications which
will run within the machines we can
choose
a machine so by default it shows one
virtual cpu core and 3.5
gigabyte of memory or ram you could
choose a higher end machine so as of now
i'll just say
n1 standard now that basically allows me
to choose these machines so there are
different features
which your compute offers such as you
have live migration for vms
you have preemptable virtual machines
you have sold tenant nodes and all those
options can be seen here
now in this machine for my boot disk i
can select
a distribution which i would be
interested in for example
i could be going for public images and i
can choose
for example ubuntu and then i can choose
a version so it shows me 16.04
and you also have latest version such as
ubuntu 20.
you can choose one of these and here it
asks you to choose the boot
disk type so that could be standard
persistent disk
which is hdds which are low in
performance
and you can say low in cost in
comparison to
ssds so ssds give you better performance
but then they are little expensive than
using
standard persistent disk we can choose
this and we can give a disk size for
example 20 gigabyte
and i can click on select before
clicking on select
i can click on custom images and that
shows me
if you have any other images created in
your project you could use those
you could also learn about images by
clicking on this link
so we'll click on public images we have
chosen this distribution
let's do a select and now here you have
identity and api access management so
let this be default
you can say allow default access and
what you need
is depending on the services we can
choose it allows http
and https traffic now we would also need
some way to connect to these machines so
when you set up an instance
by default you can do ssh into it using
the google cloud
console or from cloud shell you can also
give
a private and a public key so here you
have the option where you can give all
these details so when it comes to
management
it tells you what would you want to go
for
reservations and you can say
automatically use created reservation
you could also say no you would not want
to use a reservation
you can also set up or provide a startup
script which you would want to give
whenever your machines come up and here
you have the options of preemptability
so compute offers preemptable virtual
machines
so that is mainly when you would want to
run bad jobs
and fault tolerant workloads on these
machines
and you can benefit with a reduced cost
for your virtual cpu and memory by 80
percent
so these are virtual machines which
would be lasting less than 24 hours
now by default this is off and it purely
depends on your workload
what you would want to run on these
instances i could just go ahead
and select preemptable being on that and
use this feature of compute
you also have on host maintenance which
talks about
what would be happening with this
compute engine instance
so when compute engine performs periodic
infrastructure maintenance
it can migrate your vm instances to
other hardware
and this is one of the features which
compute
engine offers which we call as live
migration
for vms here your compute engine can
live migrate between host systems that
is the underlying systems
on which these vm instances are based on
without rebooting
which will keep your application running
even when host system require
maintenance and here it says migrate vm
instance recommended
and let that be as it is you can also
say that if there is a maintenance
happening
you can terminate the vm instance now it
also talks about automatic restart which
is on
which basically means compute engine can
automatically restart vm instances if
they are terminated from
non-user initiated reasons so these are
all the settings which are available in
management and it also tells us the
different features which we have there
is also a feature called sold tenancy
which basically means sold tenant sole
tenant nodes which can be chosen
so you can have physical compute engine
servers
dedicated exclusively for your use and
this is usually good
when you are talking about bring your
own license applications
so sole tenant nodes give you access to
same
machine types and vm configuration
options as regular
compute instances however these might be
a little expensive
we can choose this one we can also look
into networking which basically shows
the default setup
which goes for auto subnet you can also
choose a particular ip if that is
required but that would
cost more you can click on disks which
talk about what do you want to do
with the boot disk when the instance is
deleted what is the encryption mechanism
you would want to use
and here finally you have security so
basically
as i said you can ssh into instance
using the cloud console option and you
can also provide a
public ssh key so one way of doing that
if you intend to use an external ssh
client such as putty to connect
you can create a key so for example
i can go into puttygen and here i can
say generate
just move my cursor over here and that
will create a key
i can give a name to this one so i'll
say sdu
will be username i'll give a simple
password which i will use to login to
this machine
and then i can save this private key
which will get saved
so let's say hdu new key
and this gets saved in a dot ppk file
which is usually used when you use an
external ssh client to connect
so save this one and that saves a ppk
file on your desktop
what you can also do is you can copy
this
public key content from here and this is
what
we would want to give in our instance
here
so so that the public key gets stored
on the instance and private key is what
we will use to connect
so once i paste it here it resolves the
name to htu
and we have given the public key now in
certain cases you may want to
use a software which uses ssh to connect
to the machine
and that software might not be
such as your putty so in that case you
may want
a pem file or a private key which is
saved as a dot pem file
so you can also do that by going to
conversions and do export open ssh key
and then save it so i'll say hdu new key
but then this one will be saved as a pem
file
on my machine so you have ppk file which
allows you to use putty to connect to
the instance
you have a pem in case a software needs
directly
ssh to these machines you also have the
public key which we have already
provided in the machine
now once this is done i can close
puttygen
i can go back to this page where i'm
creating an instance template
and then i can just click on create so
this has created a instance template
which i can use to spin up my instances
any number of instances using the theme
template only thing which i would have
to do
is change the region where i would want
the instance to
run so now that we have created instance
and that's my
this one the third option i can go back
to vm instances
now i can click on create and here i can
either create an instance from scratch
by giving all the details again
or i can just use my template so i can
click on new vm instance from a template
choose my template click on continue and
once this is done
i can give my instance name so let's say
c1
i can choose the region so i will choose
frankfurt
and then rest everything is auto
populated
based on the template what you have
given and you click on create
now this basically allows you to spin up
an instance and you can create any
number of instances using your template
you could have already created a new
instance right from scratch
now once the instance is created this
has a public ip
and a private ip private ip will not
change
unless you would want to set up a new
machine
but public ip will change every time you
stop
and start the machine now this is what
we need to connect
to this machine i can also do a ssh from
here by doing this in
open in a browser window let's click on
this so this is an
internal way of connecting to your
instance
using ssh let's wait because it would be
transferring the ssh keys to the vm
it establishes a connection and i am
connected to my machine
what we can easily do is to confirm if
we are in the right machine
we can just do a ls to look at the file
system
what we can also do is we can basically
login as root
by doing a sudo su and that allows you
to get into
the machine as root and from here i can
switch to hdu user
which will have a dot ssh directory
in home and that basically has
authorized keys
and if we would want to see if this one
contains my public key i can just do a
cat
dot ssh and then look into authorized
keys
and this shows me the public key which
we had initially
added to our instance so this confirms
that we are logged into the machine
which we created now i can close this
and what i can also do is i can copy
this public ip
so let's do a copy to clipboard now go
to putty
and here i will say hostname
where i'll say hdu give my public key
i'll click on ssh
and in ssh i'll go to authentication now
here we need to give our ppk
file so the ppk file was sdu new key
select this one come back here come to
the session
give it a name for example c1 save it
and then you can just say open and say
yes
and you are logged in to your machine
now once you're logged in
you can always do a minus ssh and that
shows you the file
so this is how you have just used the
compute engine to spin up an instance
but we used a template which basically
allowed me
to create this instance and then i can
connect to this instance and then i can
start working on this
so when we talk about features of
compute engine it has predefined machine
types as we saw so compute engine
offers different predefined virtual
machines and this they have
configurations for every need
from small general purpose instances to
large
memory optimized instances with up to
11.5 terabytes of ram
you can have fast compute instances
optimized
up to 60 virtual cpu cores you
also have custom machine types so you
can create a vm that best
fits your workload and by tailoring a
custom machine type
to your specific need you can realize
significant
savings there are preemptable vms which
we saw there is also a facility
which allows you to take the benefit of
live migration
for vms you have durable high
performance block storage
for virtual machine instances in the
form of persistent disks
where data is stored redundantly for
integrity flexibility and to resize
storage without
interruption and you could be choosing
sdds or sdds
for your instances now you also have
option such as gpu accelerators
so for example if i just click on create
instance and i can look into that
so here let the instance name be
instance one
and what i would be interested in
looking at this one which says cpu
platform and gpu
so cpu platform configuration is
permanent you can also do
add gpu so gpus can be added to
accelerate computationally intensive
workloads like machine learning
simulation medical analysis and virtual
workstation
applications so you can add and remove
gpus to a vm
when your workload changes and pay for
gpu
only while using so these are some of
the features
which basically compute engine offers
and we already know
that google bills in second level
increments
so we only pay for the compute time now
there are
different savings which are possible so
you have commitment savings
which basically means you can save up to
57 percent without
upfront cost per instance type login
you have container support so you can
basically
run manage and orchestrate docker
containers or compute engine instances
so here when we are setting up our
instances there
is an option which basically allows you
to use
or deploy docker images now that can be
done
you can also benefit from sustained use
savings that is sustained use discounts
which are automatic discounts for
running compute engine resources for
significant portion of the billing month
you can create a reservation for vm
instance in a specific zone
which is basically seen under your
management section here
and you can ensure your project has
resources for future increases in demand
and if no longer needed delete the
reservation so these are
some of the features of compute engine
what we have done is we have created
compute
engine using the console now you can go
back
you can also do that using cloud shell
and you can click on this one which
activates cloud shell
you could also have the cloud sdk
support
on setup on your machine which can be
used now
i can just open this in a new window and
from here i can start giving commands if
i would be interested
in setting up an instance from my
command line so here you have different
options
now to begin with you can just do a g
cloud and just hit enter
and that will show you different options
which are available which can be used
so you have gcloud compute here which
shows
an option to create and manipulate
compute engine resources
now i can just do a queue to quit i can
do gcloud
compute and that basically will again
show me different
options which are available if you would
be interested in
setting up instances from the command
line
so here i can say g
cloud compute and then go for instances
and if you do not know the commands you
can just hit
enter that will show you all the
different options which we have
so here we have different options such
as list or create or start or update
for example i can just do a list here to
see
what instances i have and the instance
which we just created
shows up here it says that status is
running
i can just stop this instance i can
delete this instance
i can even create an instance by using a
create
command here and you can just do a
create help which will show you
what are the different options you can
give so it says instance name
is what you need you can choose an
accelerator
you can choose the boot disk and various
other options
so i can just say create and then
i can give a name for example c2
and once i click on this one it says
did you mean europe west 4 zone so it is
asking
me for the region and the zone and i can
say yes
and these settings are coming from my
default profile i can always change
those
by changing the metadata so now we have
created an instance
it says running if we do a list again to
see
we see two instances created one was in
europe west three one was only europius
west four
both of them have internal and external
eyepiece
now you can do a describe
to look at the different options here so
gcloud basically allows you
different commands which you can use to
work with your instance to create
instances to change the metadata if you
would want to change
the region if you would want to add a
startup script
all those options are possible from the
command line which we can learn
in detail in later sessions so this is
your compute engine as a service now
that we have learnt about
the compute domain and g
compute services which is offered by gcp
let's also learn about storage and
databases
that's again within the storage domain
and the services which are offered by
google cloud platform
now you can go back to console and here
you can click on this one
and here you can just scroll down to see
what are the different options in
storage
so you have options such as bigtable you
have data store
firestore file store you have sql based
services you have storage which is
object storage
and then you have other options which
are available so google cloud platform
offers different storage based services
out of which storage which is your
object storage is quite popular one
click on storage and that basically
shows you
an option which talks about storage
browser
so this is your google cloud's object
storage
so when we talk about object storage it
is basically
a storage where you could store any kind
of data
and when we talk about object storage it
is a bunch of bytes
which we address wherein every object
will have a unique key
these unique keys are in the form of url
which allows you to access the object
so cloud storage is comprised of what we
call as buckets
which are used to store and hold your
storage objects
the storage objects are immutable and
every change
creates a new version now you can also
have control
access via iam that is identity access
management
or via access control list so there is
also an option called object versioning
which basically says
if it is on every time you try to store
the same
object a new version of the object would
be created
otherwise newer option will override old
one
as we cannot archive the old version
so let's see how we work with this
object storage
so here you can click on create bucket
now once you click on create bucket it
needs a name so let's say
test bucket and here
i can just give say number one so that
says
this is the name of my bucket now i can
directly click on continue
or it would be good to look at different
options which are available here
so when you click on choose where to
store your data
so it already gives me an option it says
the bucket name is already
taken so let me give it a unique name so
let's say test
buck and let's call it aua
so that should be unique now here it
says
choose where to store your data so
this one gives you location type so you
can have
region specific buckets which give you
lowest latency that is fastest response
time within a single region
however it does not make your storage
highly available
you can make a dual region which is
basically allowing your bucket
or storage to be accessible across
regions
you can also make it multi-region which
is highest availability
offered as of now we can choose region
specific
and now it asks you to choose a location
now as
always i will choose frankfurt
now i can click on continue and rest all
the rest
let all the storage options be default
or you can click on a
default storage class now that tells you
based on your storage class
there are variant costs when it comes to
storing retrieving
or doing any kind of operations so you
have a standard
option which says best for short-term
storage and frequently accessed data
you can also go for cold storage such as
near line
which is best for backups and data
access less than once a month
you can go for freezing storage such as
cold line best for disaster recovery and
data accessed
less than once a quarter or you can go
for archiving
where the data is accessed less than
once a year
let's go for standard as of now and now
you can choose how to control
access to objects so you have fine
grained or uniform
let it be fine grained wherein you can
give additional permissions
at bucket level using iam or
object level permissions using access
control list
in advanced settings you can choose the
encryption
and you can also choose a retention
policy so
a retention policy to specify the
minimum duration that this buckets
objects must be protected from deletion
or modification after they are uploaded
you can always learn about this more by
clicking here
now once i have chosen all the relevant
options i can click on create
and that basically will create a bucket
by the name
i have given i can click on overview
to basically see brief details about my
bucket
such as region what is the default
storage class
and it also shows you the link url which
can be used to access your bucket
it also gives you the link for gsutil
now gsutil is a command
which can be used in your cloud shell to
basically work with your
buckets you can click on permissions to
basically see
what kind of permissions are already in
place and you can then
make changes you can basically add
members
you can view by different roles so for
example here
by default it shows other services such
as data proc
or your bucket owner or bucket reader
related permissions which have been
already granted
now once i have looked at my bucket
i can start using it i can drag and drop
and
push in files here so as of now there
are no live
objects in my object storage
that is in my bucket what i can do is i
can click on upload files
and then i can choose a location from my
machine
for example i'll go into data sets and
what i can do
is i can choose some of the files here
in any format let's choose csv
or text and just to open so this one
will basically upload my data sets
here now once i've uploaded the files i
can
basically close this one i can look into
options here which says edit permissions
and edit metadata
if you would want to download it if you
would want to copy
move or rename it if you would want to
export to
a different service called cloud pub sub
which is publish
subscribing messaging system you can
scan the data
now you can click on a particular file
and that basically shows you the url
which basically allows you to access
this file you can try copying this
you can click on download and download
this file
you can even try accessing this from
public and that basically shows you the
content of this file
based on the permissions so this is
basically
your object storage which is one of the
service which is offered
what you can also do is you can create
folders
and within folders you can then upload
your
data so this is your google cloud
storage
option which is for your object storage
that is you can add different items you
can give different permissions and you
can use this
google cloud platforms storage service
offering
now you also have other options such as
big table and we can go into that by
clicking here
and click on big table so big table
is one of the service which kickstarted
nosql
databases today in market we see
different nosql databases such
as cassandra hbase mongodb
couchdb neo4j and many others
so you can basically use bigtable
which was the pioneer when it comes to
your
no sql databases or not only sql
databases
so the problem initially faced by google
was that
the web indexes behind search engine
were taking
too long to build so company wanted to
build database that would
provide real-time access to petabytes of
data
and that's where bigtable began so big
table powers
different other google services such as
gmail
google maps and other services and in
2015
it was launched as a service for
customers
so when it comes to scalability with use
of bigtable
you can increase your machine count
without any downtime
and you can handle admin tasks like
upgrades
restarts and so on which are basically
taken care by the cloud provider
data present in cloud bigtable is
encrypted and you can
use im roles to specify access so data
written to or from big table is through
data service layers such as managed
virtual machines
hbase rest servers java services
hbs client and so on here
if i would want to use big table i can
click on create
instance and that basically tells me
cloud bigtable instance is a container
for your clusters
now here you can give an instance name
so for example
i will say aua and then
say for example test
and let's say big table so that will be
the name of instance
this will be permanent you can choose
the storage type again you can go for
lower latency more
rows red per second typically used for
real-time serving use cases
or you can go for sdds which have higher
latency for random reads
good performance on scans and typically
used for batch analytics
so let's go for ssds as of now here you
have cluster id
which is auto populated you can choose a
region
so let's go for our favorite one here
where i can say europe west 3
i can choose a zone here and i can then
choose
how many nodes would i want to use
for my big table so when you talk about
big table service
it will have a cluster underlying which
will have various nodes
which will contour your data throughput
storage and rows read per second so as
of now
let it be just one node and that's
enough for our demo
when we talk about performance it
basically tells you
based on the current node and storage
type it tells you
how many reads can happen at
milliseconds so it says 10 000 rows per
second
at 6 millisecond you have rights which
are 10 000 rows per second
or you have scans which are 220
megabytes per second storage which is
taken care here would be 2.5 terabytes
and i can then
basically click on create now there is
also some option called replication
guidance
which basically says replication for
cloud table big table copies your data
across multiple regions
enabling you to isolate workload and
increase the availability and durability
of your data
depending on your use case you can have
big table which can be used to
have your data across regions now
you can click on create with all your
specifications
chosen and that's going to set up a
cluster or you can say
a fully managed nosql database which
will give you
low latency and replication for high
availability
now once we have a new instance you can
connect to it with the cbt command line
tool
and for instructions you can click on
learn more here
you can just click on this instance id
to see the details again
if you would want to look into your big
table setup so it tells me
here that we have one instance what is
the
cpu utilization time how many rows were
read
or written what is the throughput and
this is auto populated
based on your usage you can click on
monitoring
and that basically will give you
different widgets
which will display information for your
cpu utilization
what is your hottest node depending on
how many nodes you have
system errors automatic failovers
storage utilization
and so on you can click on key
visualizer which will allow you to look
into your table
if you have already created some data
here
and you can click on tables to see how
many tables you have added here
so that's in brief about your big tables
which is
one thing which we need to remember is
it's not good for
all use cases so should be used for
low latency access that is fast access
and
good if at least data is greater than
one terabyte
for smaller amount of data the overhead
is too high so big tables performance
will suffer
if you store individual elements larger
than
10 megabytes if you want to store
bigger objects such as images video
files
then go for object storage and that
would be a better option
so always remember big table is not a
relational database
it's a no sql database and
when you talk about multi-row
transactions
or online transaction processing
bigtable is not the right choice
so it can be used for wide range of
applications
especially when you talk about your
olap that is online analytical
processing so it is designed to store
key value pairs
and there can be different use cases so
for example if you are using something
like cloud data flow
or cloud data proc where you would want
map reduce kind of operations big table
can act as a good storage
because it has very high throughput and
scalability and
the best thing is that it supports hbase
api
thus allowing easy integration with
apache hadoop and spark clusters
which you can bring up using one more
service which
google cloud platform offers which is
called cloud data proc
so bigtable is good for real-time
analytics
it's commonly seen in financial services
iot
and others and if you are thinking of
running interactive sql then bigtable
would not be the right choice
but the other choice would be bigquery
you should also remember that
this has a cluster running and you would
be
charged if this cluster kept on running
so you have to be very careful
in your free account when you're using
such services now we have
clicked on this one so i can select this
one and basically i can look at the
permissions
i can look at the labels i can look at
inherited permissions here
i can also click on my instance
which we created and either you can edit
or you can just do a delete
so as of now we will just delete this
which needs you to given that name
so we'll say aua test bt
and then click on delete so whenever you
are trying out different services
the first approach should be setting up
these different services
seeing how they work basically trying
connecting to them
and once you are satisfied with the
initial test then you can plan your
actions and come back and use the
service for a longer duration now that's
your big table
which is one of the offerings we can go
back into storage
and here you have other options which
are available
so for example we were in big table you
also have an option such as cloud
data store now that's one more
service which is offered by google cloud
platform when it comes to storage domain
so google added software on top of
bigtable which supports more than simple
key value pairs
when you talk about secondary indexes
instead of just having one primary index
when you talk about asset properties for
reliable transactions such as sql query
like language
so these features or these services were
added
to or on top of your bigtable
which gave birth to a new service which
was released as cloud data store
so this is where you have cloud data
store and you can
select a cloud firestore mode so you can
go for a native mode
enable all cloud firestores features
with offline support or you can go for
clouds data store system on top of
clouds firestore so these are different
options here
and here we look at the api or
scalability
engine support how many rights it
supports and so on
you can choose one of these and then you
can choose where to store your data so
for example if i click on this one
then it choose asks me to choose a
location so it says
the location of your database affect its
cost availability and durability
choose a regional location lower right
latency
lower cost or multi-region location here
i can basically choose for example
europe
and then i can go ahead and create a
database
so it says initializing cloud firestore
in data store mode services in
eu3 this usually takes a few minutes
you'll be
to your database once it is ready so if
we compare
the pricing structure between cloud data
store
and cloud bigtable always remember cloud
data store
you pay for monthly storage which is
also
in the case of big table however here
you are paying for monthly storage for
reads and writes
but in case of big table you are paying
for cluster
when it is running so cloud data store
is a good option
for small data infrequent access
and it acts cheaper when you talk about
large amount of data
or big data and frequent access then you
are talking about cloud bigtable
so big table is cheaper when you talk
about larger amount of data
so here it says since your database is
empty
you can still switch to cloud firestore
in native mode to get more features
you could do that you could learn you
could say query by
gql as of now we don't have any data
here
let's look at the dashboard which says
since your database is empty you can
still switch to cloud firestore
in native mode to get more features so
this is your cloud data store
and it has many features which help you
to work with your data however some
features or important features of rdbmss
were still missing
and that's where google created
yet another big table based service
called cloud spanner
now we can continue working on cloud
data store
which basically gives you one option to
work
with your data you can create an entity
here by clicking on create entity and
that basically gives you
options such as default namespace you
can give a kind
you can give numeric id and you can
start adding properties
but to learn more about data store we
will learn about this
in further session so as of now i'm
going to click on cancel
i'm going to go back to my data store
and this basically
let's go to data store option or i can
go into admin here
which basically says if you have
entities you can import or export them
so let's go back
and let's again look into storage
options
so as of now we were in data store let's
click on this
one so as i mentioned your cloud data
store which basically
gives you some additional features on
top of your big table
but what google also did was it realized
that
there was a need for rdbms
feature support that is there were a lot
of
features now here we have created a data
store and it says your data
base is ready to go just add data you
can create
entity start putting in data and then
you can go ahead and query this
so if you would want to learn more about
your data store
you can just click on this one and that
takes you to the complete documentation
of native mode and data store mode
what is firestore in native mode what is
in data store mode
what are pricing and locations how you
choose a database mode
what are the feature comparisons what
you can do what you are allowed to do
here what programming languages can be
used
different regions pricing and so on as
of now
we'll click on this one and let's look
at one advanced service
which google cloud came up with when it
comes to
your additional features of rdbms so
google created yet another big table
based service called cloud spanner now
that
you might not see here but if you scroll
down you should be
able to see your cloud spanner
in the options here or did we miss it on
the top
so let's again look here here so it is
here and you can click on spanner so
cloud spanner was released in 2017
it basically supports relational schema
so it
offers strong consistency for all
queries
which can be sql based you can have
multi-region deployment
now when it comes to massive scalability
requirement and strong consistency
cloud spanner is a good option so
it says cloud spanner is a managed
mission critical globally consistent and
scalable relational database
so if you would want to use this then
you will have to
enable this api which shows you an
option here
it says try this api so it's a managed
service so it is one of the google's
most
expensive database services there is
also one more database service which is
cloud sql
which can be used so when we talk about
your cloud spanner
it is fully managed relational database
service
it is massively distributed you can have
millions of machines
across hundreds of data centers with
support automatic sharding
and synchronous replication it gives you
low latency
and schema updates without downtime
making
data high availability and reliability
so we'll learn about cloud spanner with
more details
later in other sessions now
we can also go back to storage and we
can look at
the different options which we have here
so you have object storage you have
spanner
you also have your sql based service
which is yet another managed service
offered by
cloud or google cloud i would say so
that's called cloud sql
so this is basically a service which
allows you to have fully managed
relational
mysql postgres and sql server databases
google handles replication patch
management database management
and other things which are related to
this managed or fully managed database
service
it can allow you to handle terabytes of
storage capacity
with 40 000 iops with
huge amount of ram per instance so you
can
click on create instance here and then
you can choose
one of the database which you would want
to use so cloud sql
is a managed service you can choose one
of your mysql or postgres and sql server
say for example i choose mysql now that
basically tells me what is the instance
id it
sets up a password you can always change
the password you can change the region
you can choose your database version and
then you can also look at other
configuration options which talk about
machine type
which will be used what is about your
backup and recovery
maintenance and all that and if you
click on create
this will basically create a fully
managed
sql service which can allow you to
straight away
start using mysql on cloud thus allowing
you to store
your relational data when we talk about
storage options
how can we not talk about a data
warehouse solution
or basically an option which allows you
to run your queries by
directly updating data so you can
use a data warehouse service which
google cloud platform
offers and that's called bigquery so
basically you can be
looking into the big data section here
and here you have an option called
bigquery so
this basically brings ease of
implementation and speed
so building your own data with house can
be expensive time consuming and
difficult to scale
so with bigquery you just load data and
pay only for what you use
so it when it comes to features you have
features such as capability to process
billions of rows in seconds
and if you would want to do real time
analysis of streaming data that is also
possible here
so here we have clicked on bigquery
which basically shows you the option
where you can start
typing your query and test your data
access for example
if i have uploaded some data so
it shows me there are some queries which
are saved here
now i can schedule your query i can
basically choose
the format of a particular query by
clicking on this more
here i have an option which says add
data
so i can pin it to a particular project
i can explore public data sets i can
create a connection
so if i click on explore public data
sets then
it takes me to a page from where you can
get different kind of data sets which
are already available
which you can put into your bigquery and
start querying your data by default it
shows
that it is aligned to my project and i
don't need to worry about it
i can look at saved queries if i have
already saved
a particular query i can look at job
history i can look at transfers
scheduled queries and reservations
so bigquery basically initially
had its own version of sql which was
slightly different from standard sql but
in 2016
bigquery 2 was released that supports
sql 2011 standard
you can always select standard sql
now bigquery when it comes to pricing we
need to remember
that the storage is where the storage
cost is very less here
approximately 0.02 cents per gb
per month it is almost similar to near
line
where you can also have low cost that is
0.01 cents per gigabyte per month
there is no charge for reading data from
storage
when it comes to querying and that's
where the cost is incurred
so one terabyte per month is free and
after that
it costs few cents per gigabyte
so this is mainly for high volume
customers there is a flat rate by
pricing
which can be used so when you talk about
querying
you can save your query results you can
create data set to store the results
now results are put in a temp table in
cache
and after you are done with that you can
delete data set
and delete all the data so when you talk
about
loading data into bigquery you can get
the data from cloud storage
google drive cloud data store stack
driver stack
driver other options you have cloud big
table or
other web interfaces so you can download
from
url such as csv json avro
you can create data set create table and
create from source by doing a file
upload
so 10 megabyte or less
files can be uploaded using web
interface as an
option you can also use command line and
then you can start working with
your big query so here
you can also work with streaming data by
basically pushing in streaming data
into your bigquery which allows you to
add one record at a time
now you could use something like cloud
data flow
which allows you to use a particular
pipeline
about cloud data flow we will learn
later so you can
benefit from different features of
bigquery
and does use google's offering
to work on your structured data or i
would say
data which suits well in data warehouses
now these are some of the storage
related
services which google cloud offers
although
we will learn about using bigquery and
running
or uploading some data by creating add
data set here
by say creating connection or
using a public data set so as of now
i have this you can also access the
command line to work with this but we
will learn in detail about bigquery in
later sessions
now here you can scroll down and you
also have an
option within big data space and that is
your
data proc so when you talk about data
proc
this is again a managed service
which allows you to run spark or hadoop
jobs
so especially if you are interested in
big data workload
so for big data processing for machine
learning
you can always use cloud data proc this
uses compute engine instances under the
hood
but takes care of management of
these instances so it's a it's a layer
on top
to spin up clusters it's a managed
service it's cheaper
pay when the jobs are running only it's
fast
because it is integrated with other
google cloud services
you have open source components
pre-installed
and data proc is integrated with yarn to
make cluster management
easier when you talk about data proc you
can click on create cluster
and that basically allows you to set up
your cluster by choosing a particular
region
which you would want to use for example
i'll choose euro paste 4
here it tells what kind of machines you
would want to use
and by default it has populated as
the machine here which is 4 cpu and 15
gigabyte now since you might be using a
free account
let's not go for the high end machine
let's go for n1 standard two
and then you can scroll down it says
what is the primary disk what is the
disk type
and this one was for your master machine
that is machine which will have the
master processors running
then you have your worker node
configuration
which tells this will be let's choose a
lower
end machine and we can choose how many
worker nodes you would have so it says
minimum 2
you can choose the ssds and their
capacity it talks about yarn cores and
yarn memory which will be allocated
and here we have then
option of clicking on create so once you
click on create
this will basically spin up a cluster
wherein
you can straight away start submitting
jobs to this
you can basically go ahead once your
cluster is ready
you can go into the cluster you can
submit a job
you can choose a type which is spark or
any other application which you would
want to run and then basically
you can use this fully managed
service which allows you to run your big
data clusters
you can obviously control access via
roles
or access control list and you can have
access as it is at project level or
based on your data proc cluster or even
at your worker notes so we'll learn
about data proc in later sessions so as
of now you see here
the cluster is getting created it says
the cloud storage
bucket which it is using is this one
now i can click on this and open link in
a new tab it still takes me
into console but now it is showing me
the bucket which is being used by your
data proc cluster this is
the bucket which is being used and it is
being used for
underlying metadata which gets stored
here so you look at the cluster related
folders
you can click in these folders and then
it can see what is the script output
what it is doing
and so on now i can come back here to my
bucket
which will basically show me what kind
of buckets have been created so you see
data proc service automatically created
some buckets which will be
holding some data you also have some
other buckets which were created based
on other services which we used
the access control is fine grained in
all cases
plus it also shows our bucket so
underlying
it is using compute instances it is
basically
using let's go here and let's go to
compute engine
and let's look into vm instances so data
proc
which has spun up a cluster is also
using the vm instances which we see here
are running it is using the buckets and
it has made
a cluster ready to use so you can click
on this cluster
and that shows me my cluster related
details
if there are any jobs running what are
vm instances
what kind of configurations it has used
and you can look at
different details here you can look at
the logs you can click on jobs
and that will show you if you have
basically
run a job on this ready to use cluster
so it says there is this particular job
which was run
which was a spark job you can click on
submit
and this one tells you what is the job
id what is the region you would choose
for example we will again choose for
example europe quest
4 it tells what is the job type so you
can run
all these type of jobs in this cluster
such as hadoop spark
pi spark hive pig presto you can give
your jar file so if you are packaged
your application is a jar
you can mention that here you can pass
in some arguments
you can also say some other jar files
add some properties
and then click on submit which will run
your job on this
ready-to-use cluster now since we have
tested it
i can basically go ahead and do a delete
i don't want to incur any cost
on these managed services which are
running so there are a lot more
information about using these services
which google cloud platform
offers and we can continue learning
about these services
as we explore your google cloud console
or
even your command line option now we can
come out of this one
by clicking on this menu and then we
have other options such as kubernetes
you have cloud functions you have your
networking related services monitoring
related services
different kind of tools what you have
you have
other big data specific services which
you can learn
about and for each of these servers
google has
a very good documentation available for
example when you talk about publish
subscribe
messaging system it is a real-time
managed service
which basically is a pioneer
which was used and now you have a
famous service such as kafka which is
being used for
your publish subscribing or messaging
system kind of requirements so to
conclude
about google cloud platform services
you can always go to cloud.google.com
and look into the document section
now here you have list of different
featured
products you also have list of your
different domains and services which
google cloud
offers and you can learn about all the
different services which are offered by
google cloud
here you can click on featured products
and that basically shows you compute
engine
cloud run cloud storage you have cloud
sql bigquery
vision ai you can scroll down and look
at your artificial intelligence and
machine learning related services
platform and accelerators api management
so google cloud platform offers
different services in mainly
in your compute storage and databases
you have networking related services
big data specifics developer tools
cloud ai identity and security
iot management tools api platform
and so on so basically learn about
the gcp services which google cloud
platform
offers and in detail you can play around
with different services which are
offered
by creating a free account and as i
demonstrated
you can use any one of these services
quick start them
basically connect to them put in your
data
or use a managed service to manage your
data
and benefit from google cloud platform
thus having modernized infrastructure
for your different use cases hi guys
today we got something very special in
store for you
we're going to talk about the best cloud
computing platform available
amazon web services uh rahul i think you
said something wrong here
the best cloud computing platform is
obviously google cloud platform
no it isn't aws is more than 100
services that span a variety of domains
all right but google cloud platform has
cheaper instances what do you have to
say about that
well i guess there's only one place we
can actually discuss this a boxing ring
so guys i'm apexia and i will be google
cloud platform and i'm rahul i'll be aws
so welcome to fight night this is aws
versus gcp the winner will be chosen on
the basis of their origin
and the features they provide their
performance in the present day and
comparing them on the basis of pricing
market share and options the things they
give you for free and
instance configuration now first let's
talk about aws aws was launched in 2004
and is a cloud service platform that
helps businesses grow and scale by
providing them services in a number of
different domains these domains include
compute
database storage migration networking
and so on a very important aspect about
aws is its years of experience now
aws has been in the market a lot longer
than any other cloud service platform
which means they know how businesses
work and how they can contribute to the
business growing
also aws has over 5.1 billion dollars of
revenue in the last quarter this is a
clear indication
of how much faith and trust people have
in aws they occupy more than 40 percent
of the market which is a significant
chunk of the cloud computing market
they have at least 100 services that are
available at the moment which means
just about every issue that you have can
be solved with an aws service
now that was great but now can we talk
about gcp
i hope you know that gcp was launched
very recently in 2011 and it is already
helping businesses
significantly with the suite of
intelligent secure and flexible cloud
computing services
it lets you build deploy and scale
applications websites
services on the same infrastructure as
google
the intuitive user experience that gcp
provides with dashboards wizards
is way better in all the aspects tcp has
just stepped in the market and it is
already offering a modest number of
services
and the number is rapidly increasing and
the cost for a cpu instance or regional
storage that gcp provides is a whole lot
cheaper
and you also get a multi-regional cloud
storage now what do you have to say on
that
i'm so glad you asked let's look at
present day in fact let's look at the
cloud market share of the fourth quarter
of 2017.
this will tell you once and for all that
aws is the leader when it comes to cloud
computing
amazon web services contributes 47 of
the market share
others like rackspace or verizon cloud
contribute 36 percent microsoft azure
contributes 10 percent
the google cloud platform contributes 4
percent and ibm software contributes 3
47 of the market share is contributed by
aws
you need me to convince you any more
wait wait wait
all that is fine but we only started a
few years back
and have already grown so much in such a
less span of time
haven't you heard the latest news our
revenue is already a billion dollars per
quarter
wait for a few more years and the world
shall see and aws makes 5.3 billion
dollars per quarter
it's going to take a good long time
before you can even get close to us
yes yes we'll see now let's compare a
few things
for starters let's compare pricing for
aws a computer instance of two cpus in
8gb ram costs approximately 68 us
dollars
now a computer instance is a virtual
machine in which you can specify what
operating system
ram or storage you want to have for
cloud storage it costs 2.3 cents per gb
per month with aws
you really want to do that because gcp
wins this
hands down let's take the same compute
instance of
two cpus with 8 gb ram it will cost
approximately 50 dollars per month with
gcp
and as for my calculations that's a 25
annual cost reduction when compared to
aws talking about cloud storage costs it
is
only 2 cents per gb per month with gcp
what else do you want me to say let's
talk about market share and options
now aws is the current market leader
when it comes to cloud computing now
as you remember we contribute at least
47 percent of the entire market share
aws also has at least 100 services
available at the moment which is a clear
indication
of how well aws understands businesses
and helps them grow
yeah that's true but you should also
know that gcp is steadily growing
we have over 60 services that are up and
running
as you can see here and a lot more to
come it's only a matter of time when we
will have
as many services as you do many
companies have
already started adopting gcp as a cloud
service provider
now let's talk about things you get for
free with aws you get access to almost
all the services for an entire year with
usage limits
now these limits include an hourly or by
the minute basis for example with amazon
ec2 you get 750 hours per month you also
have limits on the number of requests to
services for example with aws lambda
you have 1 million requests per month
now after these limits across you get
charged standard rates
with gcp you get access to all cloud
platform products like
firebase the google maps api and so on
you also get 300
in credit to spend over a 12 month
period on all the cloud platform
products
and interestingly after the free trial
ends you won't be charged unless you
manually upgrade to a paid account
now there is also the always free
version for which you will need an
upgraded billing account
here you get to use a small instance for
free and 5 gb of cloud storage
any usage above this always free usage
limits will be automatically billed at
standard rates
now let's talk about how you can
configure instances with aws
the largest instance that's offered the
128 cpus and 4 tvs of ram
now other than the on-demand method like
i mentioned before
you can also use spot instances now
these are the situations where your
application is more fault tolerant and
can handle an interruption
now you pay for the spot price which is
effective at a particular r
now these part prices do fluctuate but
are adjusted over a period of time
the largest instance offered with google
cloud is 160 cpus and 3.75 tbs ram
like spot instances of aws google cloud
offers short-lived compute instances
suitable for bad jobs and fault tolerant
workloads they are called as preemptable
instances
so these instances are available at
eighty percent
off on on demand price hence they reduce
your compute engine costs
significantly and unlike aws these come
at a fixed price
google cloud platform is a lot more
flexible when it comes to instance
configuration
you simply choose your cpu and ram
combination of course
you can even create your own instance
types this way
before we wrap it up let's compare on
some other things as well
telemetry it's a process of
automatically collecting periodic
measurements from remote devices
for example gps gcp is obviously better
because they have superior telemetry
tools which help in analyzing services
and providing more opportunities for
improvement when it comes to application
support aws is
obviously better since they have years
of experience under their bed aws
provides the best support that can be
given to the customers
containers are better with gcp a
container is a virtual process running
in user space
as kubernetes was originally developed
by google
gcp has full native support for the
tools other cloud services are just fine
tuning a way to provide
kubernetes as a service also the
containers help with abstracting
applications from their environment they
originally run it
the applications can be deployed easily
regardless of their environment
when it comes to geographies aws is
better since they have a head start of a
few years
aws in this span of time has been able
to cover a larger market share
and geographical locations now it's time
for the big decision
so who's it going to be yeah who is it
going to be
gcp or aws i think i'm going to go for
choosing the right cloud computing
platform is the decision that's made on
the basis of the user
or the organization's requirement on
that note i believe it's time for us to
wrap this video up
we hope you guys enjoyed this video and
learned something new
that aws is better right no that
choosing a platform
entirely depends on you and your
organization's requirement
hello everyone welcome to this session
on google cloud platform website hosting
and let's understand what google cloud
platform offers when it comes to your
web hosting
requirements here we will learn
about google cloud web hosting some
basics of cloud computing
web hosting service providers what is
gcp
and why go for it different types of web
hosting which are possible
a use case such as lush and
a quick hands-on on using gcp for web
hosting
when you talk about cloud web hosting
google cloud has the feature of hosting
a secure
and reliable websites easily it ensures
customers and sites protection the
website is
a is hosted on a fast
and reliable network you can do more
work for less price
with google cloud now when we talk about
google cloud
it is always good to know some basics
over cloud computing
now when we talk about cloud computing
cloud computing
is basically using resources
which are provided by your cloud service
provider such as google cloud and cloud
computing
basically means using hardware and
software components
to deliver a service on a network now
here
users can access files applications
from any device that can access internet
so when we talk about
cloud computing this is basically using
services which are hosted
on the infrastructure managed by cloud
provider
when we talk about resources which can
be used that may include
big data services storage options
your computing options networking
options and various other services which
a cloud provider offers cloud computing
has various different service models
such as you have
platform as a service software as a
service
infrastructure as a service also these
days we talk about containers as a
service
and these are your different computing
service models which are being offered
by
cloud service providers which allow you
for
automatic integration with your existing
environment
or if you would want to benefit from
modernization
by using a cloud provider's
infrastructure
you have different services which are
offered
some of them are for auto software
integration
or migration backing up and restoring
data
scaling your storage capacity that is
going for an unlimited storage capacity
and
using a resource provided by
cloud service provider benefiting from
reliability cost efficiency which is
offered by
a cloud provider in this case we are
talking about google cloud
when you talk about web hosting service
providers there are various web hosting
service providers
you have aws you have squarespace
ibm cloud godaddy bluehost
and google cloud so what is gcp
and why go for it when you talk about
gcp
or as we call it as google cloud
platform it is set of cloud computing
services
provided by google that runs on the same
infrastructure that google uses for it
end user products like youtube
gmail and much more when you talk about
gcp
there are various reasons why anyone
would choose
it for their use cases now let's look at
some reasons when you talk about pricing
gcp
has better pricing compared to its
competitors
depending on the services which you
would use
whether that would be infrastructure as
a service such as using compute
engine instances and running your
applications on them
or might be a managed service such as
data proc
or big table or your big query
where you can have your hadoop clusters
running
or store huge amount of data or even
build
your data warehouse wherein you can
store structured data so there are
different services with gcp offers
and pricing has been a better option in
case of google in comparison to other
competitors
when you talk about speed and
performance it's very fast
and increases the performance of your
project if you use
different services offered by google
when you talk about live migration of
apps this is one of the features which
organizations usually like which none of
other competitors are offering when it
comes to live migration of apps
so there are specific features for
example when you talk about compute
engine there is a feature stating live
migration
wherein your resources or your instances
which are running applications would be
migrated
during say maintenance from one
underlying host to another underlying
host
without affecting your application's
performance
and you can benefit from that when you
talk about big data google cloud has
various offerings in big data space and
that's one of the advantages of gcp
in comparison to other competitors you
have different services
for your big data needs such as pub sub
for publish
subscribing messaging system or going
for data proc
which basically allows you to spin up
your hadoop and spark
clusters to run your different jobs and
so on
so when we talk about features of google
cloud platform
it offers high productivity because you
are using the resources which are
based on the same infrastructure which
google uses for its own
different use cases you can work from
anywhere
provided you have internet connection
and you can
connect to the cloud platform and use
different services offered via web you
can quickly collaborate
with different teams or different
colleagues working on different projects
which might be sharing or using
different gcp resources
you are benefiting from high security
and different encryption and security
mechanisms with gcp offers
now there are fewer sources or you could
say data
which is stored or vulnerable devices
there is high reliability
flexibility or scalability which gcp
offers
and the cost effectiveness really makes
it as a good choice
when you would want to benefit from
infrastructure modernization
and using a cloud platform solution
for your use case now when you talk
about different types of web hosting
google cloud offers three types of web
hosting
you have wordpress now it is a free and
open source content management system
you might have used in past or have
heard about wordpress where a lot of
websites are being created it is a
popular web publishing platform to
easily set up blogs and websites
and thus used by organizations or even
individual users for
having their blogs or running their
websites or
promoting their products you have lamp
which stands for linux apache mysql and
php
and lampstack consists of linux
apache http server mysql and php
and is used to host websites and web
applications
you also have your option of building
your own website
so you can develop website or web
application with your own code
directly on compute engine now let's
look at a use case
and understand what happened here when
we talk about lush
so lush was founded in 1995
it's you might have seen this brand
somewhere
in the streets it is a global cosmetics
retailer
headquartered in uk it sells a diverse
range of fresh
handmade products lush had become a
global brand with over 930 stores in 49
countries
so the challenges which were faced here
was traffic on boxing day
caused website crash for almost 18 hours
and this is something which
had a devastating effect on their
business the previous platform had no
scalability option
what was the solution the movement of
website during the peak time was easy
due to flexibility of gcp platform
with rapid vm deployment on google
compute engine
the environments were monitored and
destroyed in minutes
so the team could test and deploy at
speed
by using google cloud sql lush took
complete control
of its infrastructure and optimized its
systems for effective
scaling overall the platform resulted in
lower cost that led to a bright future
for lush
cosmetics now what was the result of all
this
the availability during peak loads was
improved because
of google compute engines auto scaling
feature
the infrastructure hosting costs were
reduced by 40 percent
streamline data center usage from 5 to 3
with google's high quality private
network
really benefited lush and it provided a
flexible
architecture and scalability for future
business
growth now what we have seen here is
that
your google cloud and its web hosting
basically offers
users to run their websites or use
a web hosting solution that can benefit
in more than
one way the simplest approach could be
seen
is by clicking and setting up a vm
instance by going to your console for
example
if we go in to the google cloud platform
clicking on console and here the easiest
way
i could test it is by going to my
compute engine vm instances
and here i can spin up an instance i can
click on create now in my previous
sessions i have
also explained about how you could
create a template and run an instance
from that we can also click on new vm
instance let's call
it new instance i will choose a region
for example frankfurt i will let it be
general purpose machines
let this machine be one virtual cpu core
and 3.75 gigabyte ram
if i am looking for a heavier website
which might have
more users logging in and so on then i
can choose a
higher configuration machine here we
have
the option to choose our distribution so
for example
i can choose ubuntu and then
i can choose a distribution version so
it let it be 16.04
we can choose the disk size to be 20
gigabyte and we can
use ssds or hdds so
as of now it is standard persistent disk
that is hdd
and that should be enough let's click on
select
here i will say allow default access i
would say allow
http and https so that if i have a
website content
hosted on this machine i can access it
over http
now here you have management options for
your instance
you have security option which basically
allows you to provide a public key
if you are interested in using an
external ssh client
to connect now i have used puttygen
and i have already created a private key
which is here i have also converted that
as a pem file
and anytime if i would want to use this
key
all i need to do is click on puttygen
where i had
earlier created this ppk file
now i can just do a load and i can
choose the key
which i have here and i can give the
pass face
click on ok and that shows you the
public key let's copy the public key
from here
let's go into our instance and i can
give this here
that resolves the name so i have the
private key saved on my machine
and public key which will be pushed into
the machine
i can click on create and that should
create my
instance to which you can connect using
ssh
from the console itself or using a
external
client such as putty which will then
need the public ip of this instance
the ppk file what we have and you can
connect to this instance what i can also
do
is i can just do a simple ssh from here
and that will basically allow me to
connect to the instance
what we also need to remember is each
instance what we create in compute is
also
having some default firewall rules now i
have connected to my instance
i can click on sudo su i can login as
root
and here if i would want i can install
a particular service so let's say apache
let's say apt-get install and then i can
say apache 2
or httpd that is basically to host
your web application so i'm installing
this service
and here i can check if the service is
running by doing a service httpd
status or i can say service
apache 2 status it says it is already
running that means the apache web server
page
will be accessible from http provided my
firewall rules allow that now before we
look into this we can also
for our instance look at the firewall
rules so here you have network details
now since we created an instance by
default google has created some
firewall rules which allow default http
https icmp your default
internal access rdp and ssh access and
here it says
these ingress rules which allow incoming
traffic
are allowed from anywhere we can
customize that as specific
ip addresses we can also look at egress
which is basically outgoing traffic and
this is again saying
my machine can connect to the external
world in different ways using different
protocols
so you can customize these firewall
rules as of now
i am going to let it be default now we
connected to our instance
from the browser and we were basically
checking
how you can use this browser by
clicking on this now what i can also do
is
here i'm logged into the instance my
apache server is running
so the best way to check if the apache
web server is accessible
via http all i need is my
public ip so let's copy this
let's go here and i will say h t t
p slash slash just give your public ip
and that shows your apache to web server
page
that means the apache service has
already been
run now here it tells if you would want
to host a particular page
what you will have to do is as it says
here
it is based on equivalent page on dbn
from which ubuntu apache packaging is
derived
if you can read this page it means
apache http server is installed
at this site is working properly now you
can replace
this file located at var www.html
index.html before continuing to operate
your http server
so this is where you can change the
particular page
and you will be able to host your web
site
on this particular ec2 instance what we
can do is we can check this
so we can go into the browser and we can
look
in var www
and that has an html folder look into
this
and as of now you have a index dot html
and that basically is the page what we
are seeing
now i can click on this one and i can
see
i have a small html page which
is basically showing me what we are
seeing on
our web server what i can also do is for
now
i can test it out and i can put in a
different html page
and see how that works so we
had basically the page here
in var www and then
we had the html folder and in html
folder
what i had was this index file so as of
now i just moved it
and i put it in a different location so
if i look in my home
hdu index.html
that shows me the complete html page
what we were seeing
on our web server and here it shows you
what this page would display if you run
it
on your http it says apache 2 ubuntu
default page
it shows it works it shows the content
and so on
so for just testing i move this page out
from this location and what i did was i
added a different page here
so that page if you look in html
and then look in my page dot html
section
i've just added some basic details of
creating html
i'm saying body i'm using marquee
and then i'm closing this with html tag
now this is a simple html page which i
created
and now what i did was once i've done
this
i basically did a service apache
restart so once you do that it will take
up your new page
and once you have done that now you can
access that
by going to your http
given your details and then basically
give your
public ip which we can get from here
and just paste it here now hit on this
so that shows me there is a mypage.html
i can click on this and that basically
shows the symbol page which i created so
as
of now this is my webpage which i have
created
and this is hosted on my compute
instance
now obviously we can create a more
complex
website backed up by a database
use php use mysql to store the data
and then host your website on a google
cloud platform service such as compute
where your actual code is running so we
can learn
about your web hosting on compute
instances
in further sessions
are you in the analytics space have you
ever wondered how data processing in the
cloud is changing the analytic space
if the answer is yes this is the course
for you
all major corporations are moving data
infrastructure and computing
to the cloud to optimize costs to make
analyzing data
seamless technology leaders like google
and amazon
are investing heavily in sas tools on
the cloud
google is a pioneer in this space the
google big
cloud data and machine learning platform
provides cloud databases
managed hadoop and spark services with
tools like
dataflow and dataproc the platform
allows for highly scalable
and reliable data processing the datalab
bigquery and cloud machine learning
features
make it a great choice for business
intelligence
large-scale analytics and machine
learning
its best-in-class performance and
low-cost
makes google cloud popular and sought
after
technology giants like spotify and apple
have implemented the google cloud
platform at their organizations
and healthcare and consumer goods
leaders like phillips and coca-cola
are migrating to google cloud for their
data analytics needs a google data
engineer with
expertise in google cloud machine
learning and
bigquery earns 102 000
per year on average and the demand for
google data engineer certifications
has never been higher simply learn's
google cloud platform big data and
machine learning fundamentals or
cpb100 course offers a thorough
overview of the google cloud platform
covering its data processing
capabilities
with various use case studies it's the
perfect course for data analysts
business analysts and data scientists
with real world experience
in querying etl data modeling or
machine learning i.t decision makers
evaluating the google cloud platform
have also found the training very useful
the course will cover everything you
need to know about the google cloud
platform
and includes eight hours of
instructor-led training
modules on big data and machine learning
with the google cloud
hi my name is randolph cale and i'm the
co-author of the google cloud platform
certification courses for google i'm
certified on the google cloud platform
an authorized google instructor and the
course advisor at simplylearn
i have over 40 years experience in the
industry spanning different roles from
development
managing cloud infrastructure to product
management i've partnered with
simplylearn
to ensure that you have the best
opportunity to become certified
in various google cloud platform
technologies
gain hands-on experience on the cloud
and make you job ready
before we discuss the course and the
reasons it will help you
let me first introduce you to google
cloud platform
when you use the google cloud platform
you are empowered to build
test and deploy applications at google
scale
the move to the cloud is happening today
there is a broad
industry adoption when i teach classes i
see the pace accelerating across all
companies
forbes projects a 19 growth rate to 140
billion us dollars on cloud services by
2019.
how can you move to the cloud how can
you make a career in this fast growing
part of the industry
your first step is establishing your
credentials in the google cloud platform
domain
and you can do that by getting certified
the google cloud platform fundamentals
course
introduces you to the google cloud
platform and shows you how you can
incorporate
cloud-based solutions into your business
strategies
the course is intended for solution
developers
system operation professionals and
solution architects planning to deploy
applications
and create application environments on
the google cloud platform
it is also appropriate for executives
and business decision makers evaluating
the potential of google cloud platform
to address their business needs
completing this course will give you the
skills
and the confidence to take full
advantage of the google cloud platform
ecosystem
simply learn offers you extensive
training to help you understand the
platform
you get eight hours of interactive
instructor-led
live online sessions along with a course
you receive a free trial account with
300 credit toward the use of google
cloud platform for 60 days
the instructors are google authorized
trainers the content is engaging
and all the topics are very well
explained with simply learn
you'll be enrolling for the online
classroom plexipass
which gives you the flexibility to
attend any of the weekday
and weekend batches according to your
convenience
another thing that's impressive is the
proactive teaching assistance
where experts resolve all your course
related project related or technical
questions while pursuing the course
so if you're looking for the training
and guidance you need to have a deeper
understanding about google cloud
platform products and services
this is the best course for you with the
course material
labs and authorized instructors with
extensive experience
i don't think you'll need to go anywhere
else take charge of your career sign up
for simply learn cp 100a training
all the best to you and with that we
have come to an end of this video on gcp
full course
i hope it was informative and
interesting if you have any questions
about the topics covered in this video
please ask anyway in the comment section
below our team will help you solve your
queries
thanks for watching stay safe and keep
learning
[Music]
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel
and click here to watch similar videos
to nerd up and get certified
click here